I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Oh, hey there. I need an update, a late to the party update.
I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Oh, hey there. I need an update, a late to the party update.|||I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Oh, hey there. I need an update, a late to the party update.
We haven't discussed if anyone finished. Heated rivalry if Sam said. started heated rivalry. I'm one episode in. One episode in? It is incredible. I see the allure. Sorry I'm late. Oh, well. Also, you guys, really quickly, we have a little bit of an Earwolf family reunion. Jordan is here. Our dear Jordan Duffy, Jordan, are you watching heated rivalry? Oh, I have seen it and I've watched it over and over again. Jordan, my friend who recommended it to me has watched it three times. Yeah, I watched it like three to five times. It's insane. It's,
We haven't discussed if anyone finished. Heated rivalry if Sam said. started heated rivalry. I'm one episode in. One episode in? It is incredible. I see the allure. Sorry I'm late. Oh, well. Also, you guys, really quickly, we have a little bit of an Earwolf family reunion. Jordan is here. Our dear Jordan Duffy, Jordan, are you watching heated rivalry? Oh, I have seen it and I've watched it over and over again. Jordan, my friend who recommended it to me has watched it three times. Yeah, I watched it like three to five times. It's insane. It's,|||We haven't discussed if anyone finished. Heated rivalry if Sam said. started heated rivalry. I'm one episode in. One episode in? It is incredible. I see the allure. Sorry I'm late. Oh, well. Also, you guys, really quickly, we have a little bit of an Earwolf family reunion. Jordan is here. Our dear Jordan Duffy, Jordan, are you watching heated rivalry? Oh, I have seen it and I've watched it over and over again. Jordan, my friend who recommended it to me has watched it three times. Yeah, I watched it like three to five times. It's insane. It's,
that good. I really love it. I finished it. I know you did because we were together on our company retreat. You guys, I have to tell you the next morning. I'm like, how'd you sleep? Jen was like, I was just going to finish one episode. I had like 20 minutes left. And then it rolled over into the next one. And then all of a sudden you watched till midnight. I stayed up till midnight because you cannot watch five and six broken up. You can't. Don't try. I'm not there yet. When it's time, make sure you leave yourself room to watch both of the kids. these episodes. Guys, it started off kind of just like super sexy time, but it ends like deeply moving. Am I right, Jordan? One hundred percent. You're right. Dear God. All right. I got to catch up. Matt,
that good. I really love it. I finished it. I know you did because we were together on our company retreat. You guys, I have to tell you the next morning. I'm like, how'd you sleep? Jen was like, I was just going to finish one episode. I had like 20 minutes left. And then it rolled over into the next one. And then all of a sudden you watched till midnight. I stayed up till midnight because you cannot watch five and six broken up. You can't. Don't try. I'm not there yet. When it's time, make sure you leave yourself room to watch both of the kids. these episodes. Guys, it started off kind of just like super sexy time, but it ends like deeply moving. Am I right, Jordan? One hundred percent. You're right. Dear God. All right. I got to catch up. Matt,|||that good. I really love it. I finished it. I know you did because we were together on our company retreat. You guys, I have to tell you the next morning. I'm like, how'd you sleep? Jen was like, I was just going to finish one episode. I had like 20 minutes left. And then it rolled over into the next one. And then all of a sudden you watched till midnight. I stayed up till midnight because you cannot watch five and six broken up. You can't. Don't try. I'm not there yet. When it's time, make sure you leave yourself room to watch both of the kids. these episodes. Guys, it started off kind of just like super sexy time, but it ends like deeply moving. Am I right, Jordan? One hundred percent. You're right. Dear God. All right. I got to catch up. Matt,
how's it for you? Where are you at? Well, I got caught up with another late to the party sexy time thing, so I'm a bit on hold. I started watching industry. Oh, I don't know it. It's sexy? It's also super sexy time in a different way, but some of the same ways as heated rivalry. So I got a little caught up with that. I don't know anything about industry. It's about bankers in London. Sounds hot. Sounds really hot. It's very good. I recommend it. All right. Well, there's our late to the party. Why don't we kick off this episode, lady? Today's episode is really fun. We're going to give you some office news. We're going to share a little bit about this blackmail web episode featuring Creed Bratton. And of course, we've got some chit-chats. Why don't we start with the chit-chat? All right, this one's coming from
how's it for you? Where are you at? Well, I got caught up with another late to the party sexy time thing, so I'm a bit on hold. I started watching industry. Oh, I don't know it. It's sexy? It's also super sexy time in a different way, but some of the same ways as heated rivalry. So I got a little caught up with that. I don't know anything about industry. It's about bankers in London. Sounds hot. Sounds really hot. It's very good. I recommend it. All right. Well, there's our late to the party. Why don't we kick off this episode, lady? Today's episode is really fun. We're going to give you some office news. We're going to share a little bit about this blackmail web episode featuring Creed Bratton. And of course, we've got some chit-chats. Why don't we start with the chit-chat? All right, this one's coming from|||how's it for you? Where are you at? Well, I got caught up with another late to the party sexy time thing, so I'm a bit on hold. I started watching industry. Oh, I don't know it. It's sexy? It's also super sexy time in a different way, but some of the same ways as heated rivalry. So I got a little caught up with that. I don't know anything about industry. It's about bankers in London. Sounds hot. Sounds really hot. It's very good. I recommend it. All right. Well, there's our late to the party. Why don't we kick off this episode, lady? Today's episode is really fun. We're going to give you some office news. We're going to share a little bit about this blackmail web episode featuring Creed Bratton. And of course, we've got some chit-chats. Why don't we start with the chit-chat? All right, this one's coming from
Carolyn M in Vermont. Hi, office ladies. This is Carolyn from Vermont. I don't know what cold and flu season has been like in California, but in Vermont, it's been the pits. Whenever we're sick, I like to make soup. I had the pleasure of interviewing Angela and Josh about their cookbook, and the first recipe that I made was the Italian wedding soup that's in the book. I know Angela made that for Josh when he was sick when they were first dating. and now it's our go-to recipe when my family is sick. So I was wondering what your go-to soup recipe is when you're sick. I just love this question.
Carolyn M in Vermont. Hi, office ladies. This is Carolyn from Vermont. I don't know what cold and flu season has been like in California, but in Vermont, it's been the pits. Whenever we're sick, I like to make soup. I had the pleasure of interviewing Angela and Josh about their cookbook, and the first recipe that I made was the Italian wedding soup that's in the book. I know Angela made that for Josh when he was sick when they were first dating. and now it's our go-to recipe when my family is sick. So I was wondering what your go-to soup recipe is when you're sick. I just love this question.|||Carolyn M in Vermont. Hi, office ladies. This is Carolyn from Vermont. I don't know what cold and flu season has been like in California, but in Vermont, it's been the pits. Whenever we're sick, I like to make soup. I had the pleasure of interviewing Angela and Josh about their cookbook, and the first recipe that I made was the Italian wedding soup that's in the book. I know Angela made that for Josh when he was sick when they were first dating. and now it's our go-to recipe when my family is sick. So I was wondering what your go-to soup recipe is when you're sick. I just love this question.
I didn't pick it, you guys. I promise. Jenna picked this one. But I did love it. And here's the funny thing. I made Josh this soup. You guys, I destroyed my kitchen because I didn't know how to cook it all at the time. And I had no idea how many steps and how many ingredients.
I didn't pick it, you guys. I promise. Jenna picked this one. But I did love it. And here's the funny thing. I made Josh this soup. You guys, I destroyed my kitchen because I didn't know how to cook it all at the time. And I had no idea how many steps and how many ingredients.|||I didn't pick it, you guys. I promise. Jenna picked this one. But I did love it. And here's the funny thing. I made Josh this soup. You guys, I destroyed my kitchen because I didn't know how to cook it all at the time. And I had no idea how many steps and how many ingredients.
And so my kitchen was a hot mess. But I show up to Josh's apartment with that. this big pot of soup. And he says that was the moment. He was like, oh my gosh, I have to marry this woman. She's going to make me soup for the rest of my life. And of course, like, he is the cook of the family. But I loved this question. Jenna, you love soup. Is there one that's your go-to? Well, I have a go-to soup, but it's different than the soup I like to eat when I'm sick. Oh, okay. So when I'm sick, I just want a chicken noodle. Yeah.
And so my kitchen was a hot mess. But I show up to Josh's apartment with that. this big pot of soup. And he says that was the moment. He was like, oh my gosh, I have to marry this woman. She's going to make me soup for the rest of my life. And of course, like, he is the cook of the family. But I loved this question. Jenna, you love soup. Is there one that's your go-to? Well, I have a go-to soup, but it's different than the soup I like to eat when I'm sick. Oh, okay. So when I'm sick, I just want a chicken noodle. Yeah.|||And so my kitchen was a hot mess. But I show up to Josh's apartment with that. this big pot of soup. And he says that was the moment. He was like, oh my gosh, I have to marry this woman. She's going to make me soup for the rest of my life. And of course, like, he is the cook of the family. But I loved this question. Jenna, you love soup. Is there one that's your go-to? Well, I have a go-to soup, but it's different than the soup I like to eat when I'm sick. Oh, okay. So when I'm sick, I just want a chicken noodle. Yeah.
You know? Mm-hmm. Although Josh made me some delicious kind of a spin on a chicken noodle that was kind of a lemony chicken orzo. Oh, yeah. That you guys gave me when I was doing chemo. That's right. Oh, I loved that. That was great.
You know? Mm-hmm. Although Josh made me some delicious kind of a spin on a chicken noodle that was kind of a lemony chicken orzo. Oh, yeah. That you guys gave me when I was doing chemo. That's right. Oh, I loved that. That was great.|||You know? Mm-hmm. Although Josh made me some delicious kind of a spin on a chicken noodle that was kind of a lemony chicken orzo. Oh, yeah. That you guys gave me when I was doing chemo. That's right. Oh, I loved that. That was great.
But my favorite soup to make is a soup that I made up myself. Isn't that so rewarding? Yeah. And you can make soup just like on your own? Well, I listened to this podcast by Kendra Adachi, where she's, She basically says you can make soup without a recipe, and I'm going to tell you how. Now, you wouldn't think that you could learn how to make soup without a recipe by listening to a 15-minute podcast, but you can, and I did.
But my favorite soup to make is a soup that I made up myself. Isn't that so rewarding? Yeah. And you can make soup just like on your own? Well, I listened to this podcast by Kendra Adachi, where she's, She basically says you can make soup without a recipe, and I'm going to tell you how. Now, you wouldn't think that you could learn how to make soup without a recipe by listening to a 15-minute podcast, but you can, and I did.|||But my favorite soup to make is a soup that I made up myself. Isn't that so rewarding? Yeah. And you can make soup just like on your own? Well, I listened to this podcast by Kendra Adachi, where she's, She basically says you can make soup without a recipe, and I'm going to tell you how. Now, you wouldn't think that you could learn how to make soup without a recipe by listening to a 15-minute podcast, but you can, and I did.
She explains, like, pick your veggies, pick your protein, pick your broth, and I'm going to tell you what order to put it in, pick your aromatics, here's how you make soup. And she's like, and you can just change it up whenever you want. You don't need a recipe. She's so right. So I use a turkey sausage. I use kale, spinach, celery, carrots, onions, garlic, some oregano, a little basil, and a pinch of red pepper flakes. I'll tell you what I don't put in my soup, though. What?
She explains, like, pick your veggies, pick your protein, pick your broth, and I'm going to tell you what order to put it in, pick your aromatics, here's how you make soup. And she's like, and you can just change it up whenever you want. You don't need a recipe. She's so right. So I use a turkey sausage. I use kale, spinach, celery, carrots, onions, garlic, some oregano, a little basil, and a pinch of red pepper flakes. I'll tell you what I don't put in my soup, though. What?|||She explains, like, pick your veggies, pick your protein, pick your broth, and I'm going to tell you what order to put it in, pick your aromatics, here's how you make soup. And she's like, and you can just change it up whenever you want. You don't need a recipe. She's so right. So I use a turkey sausage. I use kale, spinach, celery, carrots, onions, garlic, some oregano, a little basil, and a pinch of red pepper flakes. I'll tell you what I don't put in my soup, though. What?
Bay leaves. Do you remember those? Yeah, yeah, because I've made some soups where you add them at the end, you kind of fold them into the soup at the end. You don't like it? my mom would always make this veggie soup when I was a kid, and you're supposed to put them in, and then you leave them in for like a long period of time, I think. And then before you serve the soup,
Bay leaves. Do you remember those? Yeah, yeah, because I've made some soups where you add them at the end, you kind of fold them into the soup at the end. You don't like it? my mom would always make this veggie soup when I was a kid, and you're supposed to put them in, and then you leave them in for like a long period of time, I think. And then before you serve the soup,|||Bay leaves. Do you remember those? Yeah, yeah, because I've made some soups where you add them at the end, you kind of fold them into the soup at the end. You don't like it? my mom would always make this veggie soup when I was a kid, and you're supposed to put them in, and then you leave them in for like a long period of time, I think. And then before you serve the soup,
you're supposed to take them out because they're not edible. No, you take them out. You take them out. They're just for soaking. And the flavor. Right. But my mom would always forget to take them out. Oh.
you're supposed to take them out because they're not edible. No, you take them out. You take them out. They're just for soaking. And the flavor. Right. But my mom would always forget to take them out. Oh.|||you're supposed to take them out because they're not edible. No, you take them out. You take them out. They're just for soaking. And the flavor. Right. But my mom would always forget to take them out. Oh.
So then you'd go to take a bite of your soup, and inevitably someone would end up with the bay leaf. and you'd have to like fish it out of your mouth. This is like finding like the baby Jesus in a king cake. A little bit. Okay. But so maybe you don't mind the flavor of bay leaf. Maybe you just don't want to eat it.
So then you'd go to take a bite of your soup, and inevitably someone would end up with the bay leaf. and you'd have to like fish it out of your mouth. This is like finding like the baby Jesus in a king cake. A little bit. Okay. But so maybe you don't mind the flavor of bay leaf. Maybe you just don't want to eat it.|||So then you'd go to take a bite of your soup, and inevitably someone would end up with the bay leaf. and you'd have to like fish it out of your mouth. This is like finding like the baby Jesus in a king cake. A little bit. Okay. But so maybe you don't mind the flavor of bay leaf. Maybe you just don't want to eat it.
Well, I got curious about bay leaves when I knew we were going to have to answer this question because I was like, what are they and what do they taste like? Because I haven't missed them. So I looked it up and it says bay leaves are from the bay laurel tree. and they add aromatic tones to the soup and that the flavor is kind of like herbal tea or a minty clove. And by the way, there are a gazillion
Well, I got curious about bay leaves when I knew we were going to have to answer this question because I was like, what are they and what do they taste like? Because I haven't missed them. So I looked it up and it says bay leaves are from the bay laurel tree. and they add aromatic tones to the soup and that the flavor is kind of like herbal tea or a minty clove. And by the way, there are a gazillion|||Well, I got curious about bay leaves when I knew we were going to have to answer this question because I was like, what are they and what do they taste like? Because I haven't missed them. So I looked it up and it says bay leaves are from the bay laurel tree. and they add aromatic tones to the soup and that the flavor is kind of like herbal tea or a minty clove. And by the way, there are a gazillion
Reddit threads and articles dedicated to the question, do you really need a bay leaf in your soup? It's like a whole thing in the soup community. That's the internet I'm here for. Yeah. I read tons of articles about it. Yeah.
Reddit threads and articles dedicated to the question, do you really need a bay leaf in your soup? It's like a whole thing in the soup community. That's the internet I'm here for. Yeah. I read tons of articles about it. Yeah.|||Reddit threads and articles dedicated to the question, do you really need a bay leaf in your soup? It's like a whole thing in the soup community. That's the internet I'm here for. Yeah. I read tons of articles about it. Yeah.
Well, I don't mind it, But, Sam, anyone else have a soup that they like? Yeah, when I'm sick, I like Campbell's Bean Soup and Sprite and Saltines. That's the perfect meal. Do you crush up the saltines in the soup? You don't. Oh, I love to crush. Do you dip them?
Well, I don't mind it, But, Sam, anyone else have a soup that they like? Yeah, when I'm sick, I like Campbell's Bean Soup and Sprite and Saltines. That's the perfect meal. Do you crush up the saltines in the soup? You don't. Oh, I love to crush. Do you dip them?|||Well, I don't mind it, But, Sam, anyone else have a soup that they like? Yeah, when I'm sick, I like Campbell's Bean Soup and Sprite and Saltines. That's the perfect meal. Do you crush up the saltines in the soup? You don't. Oh, I love to crush. Do you dip them?
Nope. Oh, on the side. Sam. I know. I'm wild. Gosh, I love a salty cracker crushed up in a soup. Crushed in it. Well, you know, you crack it.
Nope. Oh, on the side. Sam. I know. I'm wild. Gosh, I love a salty cracker crushed up in a soup. Crushed in it. Well, you know, you crack it.|||Nope. Oh, on the side. Sam. I know. I'm wild. Gosh, I love a salty cracker crushed up in a soup. Crushed in it. Well, you know, you crack it.
I don't want to stick the whole square in my soup. I break it up. I only like those little oyster round things in a clam chowder. I get so excited if I'm at dinner with someone and they get clam chowder and they don't want those, I'm like, you're going to eat those? Yeah. Pass them over here. Those are great.
I don't want to stick the whole square in my soup. I break it up. I only like those little oyster round things in a clam chowder. I get so excited if I'm at dinner with someone and they get clam chowder and they don't want those, I'm like, you're going to eat those? Yeah. Pass them over here. Those are great.|||I don't want to stick the whole square in my soup. I break it up. I only like those little oyster round things in a clam chowder. I get so excited if I'm at dinner with someone and they get clam chowder and they don't want those, I'm like, you're going to eat those? Yeah. Pass them over here. Those are great.
Great. Jordan. I also like a chicken noodle, but in mixture, I do crunch up the crackers and put them in because they like thicken up the soup. Yes, they do, Jordan. Yes, they do. Mm-hmm. I see you.
Great. Jordan. I also like a chicken noodle, but in mixture, I do crunch up the crackers and put them in because they like thicken up the soup. Yes, they do, Jordan. Yes, they do. Mm-hmm. I see you.|||Great. Jordan. I also like a chicken noodle, but in mixture, I do crunch up the crackers and put them in because they like thicken up the soup. Yes, they do, Jordan. Yes, they do. Mm-hmm. I see you.
Matt, you want to weigh in on the soups? I do. I'm a big Mexican soup guy. So Pesole is my go-to and sick. I make it with chicken. Are you all familiar with Pesole? No, is it spicy? Maybe a little bit, but it's with like tomatoos and meat.
Matt, you want to weigh in on the soups? I do. I'm a big Mexican soup guy. So Pesole is my go-to and sick. I make it with chicken. Are you all familiar with Pesole? No, is it spicy? Maybe a little bit, but it's with like tomatoos and meat.|||Matt, you want to weigh in on the soups? I do. I'm a big Mexican soup guy. So Pesole is my go-to and sick. I make it with chicken. Are you all familiar with Pesole? No, is it spicy? Maybe a little bit, but it's with like tomatoos and meat.
It's usually with pork, but I make it with chicken. And then you put hominy in, which is like the puffed corn, which is rare, but really featured in this dish. And it just, it's amazing. It's like a soup that has that magic in it. That sounds great. My favorite is the Josh's chicken. chicken lemon orzo soup. So you know what, guys, I'm going to share in our stories. Everyone send me
It's usually with pork, but I make it with chicken. And then you put hominy in, which is like the puffed corn, which is rare, but really featured in this dish. And it just, it's amazing. It's like a soup that has that magic in it. That sounds great. My favorite is the Josh's chicken. chicken lemon orzo soup. So you know what, guys, I'm going to share in our stories. Everyone send me|||It's usually with pork, but I make it with chicken. And then you put hominy in, which is like the puffed corn, which is rare, but really featured in this dish. And it just, it's amazing. It's like a soup that has that magic in it. That sounds great. My favorite is the Josh's chicken. chicken lemon orzo soup. So you know what, guys, I'm going to share in our stories. Everyone send me
their link for their soups. And anyone listening who loves the soup, it'll be in our Insta stories. And I'll share Kendra's episode where she talks about soup. Yeah, because then you can make any soup you want. That's right. All right. Well, that was fun. Why don't we take a break? And then when we get back, we're going to discuss some office news and blackmail. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve.
their link for their soups. And anyone listening who loves the soup, it'll be in our Insta stories. And I'll share Kendra's episode where she talks about soup. Yeah, because then you can make any soup you want. That's right. All right. Well, that was fun. Why don't we take a break? And then when we get back, we're going to discuss some office news and blackmail. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve.|||their link for their soups. And anyone listening who loves the soup, it'll be in our Insta stories. And I'll share Kendra's episode where she talks about soup. Yeah, because then you can make any soup you want. That's right. All right. Well, that was fun. Why don't we take a break? And then when we get back, we're going to discuss some office news and blackmail. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve.
Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. Better help makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works. With an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. Better help makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works. With an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.|||Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. Better help makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works. With an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
That's better. H-E-L-P.com slash office. ladies. Hey guys, Willie Geist here reminding you to check out the Sunday Sit Down podcast. On this week's episode, I get together with music superstar Charlie Puth to talk about his nailing the national anthem at this year's Super Bowl and the inspiration for his new album drawn from a line about him in a recent Taylor Swift song. You can get our conversation now for free wherever you download your podcasts. Right. We are back. And, you know, we've been breaking. breaking down the paper for the last nine weeks, and we wanted to come back and hit you with some office news. Because a lot has happened in the universe of the office. We have a lot to share.
That's better. H-E-L-P.com slash office. ladies. Hey guys, Willie Geist here reminding you to check out the Sunday Sit Down podcast. On this week's episode, I get together with music superstar Charlie Puth to talk about his nailing the national anthem at this year's Super Bowl and the inspiration for his new album drawn from a line about him in a recent Taylor Swift song. You can get our conversation now for free wherever you download your podcasts. Right. We are back. And, you know, we've been breaking. breaking down the paper for the last nine weeks, and we wanted to come back and hit you with some office news. Because a lot has happened in the universe of the office. We have a lot to share.|||That's better. H-E-L-P.com slash office. ladies. Hey guys, Willie Geist here reminding you to check out the Sunday Sit Down podcast. On this week's episode, I get together with music superstar Charlie Puth to talk about his nailing the national anthem at this year's Super Bowl and the inspiration for his new album drawn from a line about him in a recent Taylor Swift song. You can get our conversation now for free wherever you download your podcasts. Right. We are back. And, you know, we've been breaking. breaking down the paper for the last nine weeks, and we wanted to come back and hit you with some office news. Because a lot has happened in the universe of the office. We have a lot to share.
So let's start things off with a conversation about the fact that the season nine superfan episodes are out. Yes, Dave Rogers has finished them. He's finished super fans of the whole series. Bless his heart. That was a lot of work. That was a lot of work. I know. He said he spent his whole summer on it. Yeah. Well, I want to tell you guys how to find them because Dave worked so hard and he did a fantastic job. They're over on Peacock, but I want to tell you how they're labeled. They made this whole graphic. It says, the office superfan episodes. And then in like huge letters, it says, complete collection. Because they're done. Because they're done. Mm-hmm. Well, Dave sent me a list of highlights of the new stuff they added. And it's pretty
So let's start things off with a conversation about the fact that the season nine superfan episodes are out. Yes, Dave Rogers has finished them. He's finished super fans of the whole series. Bless his heart. That was a lot of work. That was a lot of work. I know. He said he spent his whole summer on it. Yeah. Well, I want to tell you guys how to find them because Dave worked so hard and he did a fantastic job. They're over on Peacock, but I want to tell you how they're labeled. They made this whole graphic. It says, the office superfan episodes. And then in like huge letters, it says, complete collection. Because they're done. Because they're done. Mm-hmm. Well, Dave sent me a list of highlights of the new stuff they added. And it's pretty|||So let's start things off with a conversation about the fact that the season nine superfan episodes are out. Yes, Dave Rogers has finished them. He's finished super fans of the whole series. Bless his heart. That was a lot of work. That was a lot of work. I know. He said he spent his whole summer on it. Yeah. Well, I want to tell you guys how to find them because Dave worked so hard and he did a fantastic job. They're over on Peacock, but I want to tell you how they're labeled. They made this whole graphic. It says, the office superfan episodes. And then in like huge letters, it says, complete collection. Because they're done. Because they're done. Mm-hmm. Well, Dave sent me a list of highlights of the new stuff they added. And it's pretty
great. I'm going to just tell you a few. In episode, here comes trouble. Andy sings his signature song, Faith at the end. Get out. Yeah. So you can see that. In the target, they added back that deleted scene of Thanksgiving at the office. Oh, wow. So officially there is an office Thanksgiving moment. Now there is. He said there's also some great ads with Jim and Phyllis and Stanley going to lunch, and at the restaurant, and there's a lot more of Angela and Trevor talking in the van. He said there's also a new talking head from Pam where she talks about taking risks and wakeboarding, which I love, he said. I want to see that.
great. I'm going to just tell you a few. In episode, here comes trouble. Andy sings his signature song, Faith at the end. Get out. Yeah. So you can see that. In the target, they added back that deleted scene of Thanksgiving at the office. Oh, wow. So officially there is an office Thanksgiving moment. Now there is. He said there's also some great ads with Jim and Phyllis and Stanley going to lunch, and at the restaurant, and there's a lot more of Angela and Trevor talking in the van. He said there's also a new talking head from Pam where she talks about taking risks and wakeboarding, which I love, he said. I want to see that.|||great. I'm going to just tell you a few. In episode, here comes trouble. Andy sings his signature song, Faith at the end. Get out. Yeah. So you can see that. In the target, they added back that deleted scene of Thanksgiving at the office. Oh, wow. So officially there is an office Thanksgiving moment. Now there is. He said there's also some great ads with Jim and Phyllis and Stanley going to lunch, and at the restaurant, and there's a lot more of Angela and Trevor talking in the van. He said there's also a new talking head from Pam where she talks about taking risks and wakeboarding, which I love, he said. I want to see that.
I know. I don't even remember doing a talking head about wakeboarding. Pam wakeboards? Well, I don't know. I haven't gone in to look at the details. We'll have to dig into it. Okay. Also, in episode.
I know. I don't even remember doing a talking head about wakeboarding. Pam wakeboards? Well, I don't know. I haven't gone in to look at the details. We'll have to dig into it. Okay. Also, in episode.|||I know. I don't even remember doing a talking head about wakeboarding. Pam wakeboards? Well, I don't know. I haven't gone in to look at the details. We'll have to dig into it. Okay. Also, in episode.
episode 12, there is a new cold open that is a deleted scene where everyone is absorbed in their phones. I remember shooting that. I do too. And I know they wrote that because we all used to come to set around this time and we were all absorbed in our phones. And I felt like it was a little like subtle. Like a dig. Yeah. Like they were making fun of us. Well, come on. We're old. We all like over one summer switch from flip phones. Yep. To like blackberries. And then we finally got those like the very first version of a smartphone. Yes. And we were like little kids. I was Blackberry for a long time. Same. I was very resistant to changing because I liked that the keys actually clicked. Me too. Like you felt the resistance when you touched them. I still hate the like typing on my iPhone.
episode 12, there is a new cold open that is a deleted scene where everyone is absorbed in their phones. I remember shooting that. I do too. And I know they wrote that because we all used to come to set around this time and we were all absorbed in their phones. And I felt like it was a little like subtle. Like a dig. Yeah. Like they were making fun of us. Well, come on. We're old. We all like over one summer switch from flip phones. Yep. To like blackberries. And then we finally got those like the very first version of a smartphone. Yes. And we were like little kids. I was Blackberry for a long time. Same. I was very resistant to changing because I liked that the keys actually clicked. Me too. Like you felt the resistance when you touched them. I still hate the like typing on my iPhone.|||episode 12, there is a new cold open that is a deleted scene where everyone is absorbed in their phones. I remember shooting that. I do too. And I know they wrote that because we all used to come to set around this time and we were all absorbed in their phones. And I felt like it was a little like subtle. Like a dig. Yeah. Like they were making fun of us. Well, come on. We're old. We all like over one summer switch from flip phones. Yep. To like blackberries. And then we finally got those like the very first version of a smartphone. Yes. And we were like little kids. I was Blackberry for a long time. Same. I was very resistant to changing because I liked that the keys actually clicked. Me too. Like you felt the resistance when you touched them. I still hate the like typing on my iPhone.
Do you have the setting where it clicks so you hear it? No. No. Do you? I used to, but it drove everyone crazy. around. But I think it's because it's a holdover from the Blackberry. I liked the little click, the little sound. So my problem is two things. When I go to hit the letter N, sometimes I hit the space bar instead, and it bothers me. Or sometimes when I mean to hit the space bar, I accidentally hit the period. And that really messes me up because when I'm trying to Google something or search for something, if I put a period instead of a space, it thinks I want to go to a website and then it tells me that you're making no sense, lady.
Do you have the setting where it clicks so you hear it? No. No. Do you? I used to, but it drove everyone crazy. around. But I think it's because it's a holdover from the Blackberry. I liked the little click, the little sound. So my problem is two things. When I go to hit the letter N, sometimes I hit the space bar instead, and it bothers me. Or sometimes when I mean to hit the space bar, I accidentally hit the period. And that really messes me up because when I'm trying to Google something or search for something, if I put a period instead of a space, it thinks I want to go to a website and then it tells me that you're making no sense, lady.|||Do you have the setting where it clicks so you hear it? No. No. Do you? I used to, but it drove everyone crazy. around. But I think it's because it's a holdover from the Blackberry. I liked the little click, the little sound. So my problem is two things. When I go to hit the letter N, sometimes I hit the space bar instead, and it bothers me. Or sometimes when I mean to hit the space bar, I accidentally hit the period. And that really messes me up because when I'm trying to Google something or search for something, if I put a period instead of a space, it thinks I want to go to a website and then it tells me that you're making no sense, lady.
Yeah. So I still don't like it. I wish the period was somewhere else. I don't know. Can you all move the period? I'd appreciate it. How about that for an update that I actually want? You know what update I didn't need is making my screen look like glass.
Yeah. So I still don't like it. I wish the period was somewhere else. I don't know. Can you all move the period? I'd appreciate it. How about that for an update that I actually want? You know what update I didn't need is making my screen look like glass.|||Yeah. So I still don't like it. I wish the period was somewhere else. I don't know. Can you all move the period? I'd appreciate it. How about that for an update that I actually want? You know what update I didn't need is making my screen look like glass.
Oh, yeah. I don't want to look at glass. I also don't like the photo update, like where your photos are kept. It's all different. I don't like it. Sam Jordan are nodding. They're nodding. What's happening?
Oh, yeah. I don't want to look at glass. I also don't like the photo update, like where your photos are kept. It's all different. I don't like it. Sam Jordan are nodding. They're nodding. What's happening?|||Oh, yeah. I don't want to look at glass. I also don't like the photo update, like where your photos are kept. It's all different. I don't like it. Sam Jordan are nodding. They're nodding. What's happening?
No, I was nodding with furious agreement. Oh, thank you. It's my phone's, I hate it now. Yeah, I hate it. Yeah. I do remember I have such a strong visual lady of being on set with you. And we would want to like, oh, should we answer this email or something? Like maybe we needed to respond to something.
No, I was nodding with furious agreement. Oh, thank you. It's my phone's, I hate it now. Yeah, I hate it. Yeah. I do remember I have such a strong visual lady of being on set with you. And we would want to like, oh, should we answer this email or something? Like maybe we needed to respond to something.|||No, I was nodding with furious agreement. Oh, thank you. It's my phone's, I hate it now. Yeah, I hate it. Yeah. I do remember I have such a strong visual lady of being on set with you. And we would want to like, oh, should we answer this email or something? Like maybe we needed to respond to something.
And you'd be like, I'll do it. And you are the fastest thumb typeer in the world. Wow. You just won that award. There's your Dundee. Okay, I have a few more things to share about the superfan episodes. Dave said episode Vandalism has a ton of great ads throughout, especially with Pam Dwight and Clark in the warehouse.
And you'd be like, I'll do it. And you are the fastest thumb typeer in the world. Wow. You just won that award. There's your Dundee. Okay, I have a few more things to share about the superfan episodes. Dave said episode Vandalism has a ton of great ads throughout, especially with Pam Dwight and Clark in the warehouse.|||And you'd be like, I'll do it. And you are the fastest thumb typeer in the world. Wow. You just won that award. There's your Dundee. Okay, I have a few more things to share about the superfan episodes. Dave said episode Vandalism has a ton of great ads throughout, especially with Pam Dwight and Clark in the warehouse.
He said there is also just more Nate overall, including an ad lib that led to the famous blooper. Frank did it, did it? Yeah. Here is a really good one, though. Episode 17, more Bob Odenkirk. Really? He said there's extra scenes of me and Bob, and they're really great.
He said there is also just more Nate overall, including an ad lib that led to the famous blooper. Frank did it, did it? Yeah. Here is a really good one, though. Episode 17, more Bob Odenkirk. Really? He said there's extra scenes of me and Bob, and they're really great.|||He said there is also just more Nate overall, including an ad lib that led to the famous blooper. Frank did it, did it? Yeah. Here is a really good one, though. Episode 17, more Bob Odenkirk. Really? He said there's extra scenes of me and Bob, and they're really great.
And finally, he said the finale has a lot more cool moments, including just some Easter eggs for us of other people who were part of the show. And he said it's really fun to see, and maybe fans will also appreciate them, especially now that they know, like, a lot of people's names. Yeah. and what their jobs were. Now you can put a face to the name. Dave, I love this list.
And finally, he said the finale has a lot more cool moments, including just some Easter eggs for us of other people who were part of the show. And he said it's really fun to see, and maybe fans will also appreciate them, especially now that they know, like, a lot of people's names. Yeah. and what their jobs were. Now you can put a face to the name. Dave, I love this list.|||And finally, he said the finale has a lot more cool moments, including just some Easter eggs for us of other people who were part of the show. And he said it's really fun to see, and maybe fans will also appreciate them, especially now that they know, like, a lot of people's names. Yeah. and what their jobs were. Now you can put a face to the name. Dave, I love this list.
It's making me all nostalgic. I know. To like go back and rewatch. Well, thank you, Dave Rogers, for all of the time you put into these superfan episodes. I really now have a few I want to go back and watch. For sure. I have to watch Andy Sing Faith.
It's making me all nostalgic. I know. To like go back and rewatch. Well, thank you, Dave Rogers, for all of the time you put into these superfan episodes. I really now have a few I want to go back and watch. For sure. I have to watch Andy Sing Faith.|||It's making me all nostalgic. I know. To like go back and rewatch. Well, thank you, Dave Rogers, for all of the time you put into these superfan episodes. I really now have a few I want to go back and watch. For sure. I have to watch Andy Sing Faith.
Yeah. That's my number one, I think. All right. Well, now we have some news from our office universe. This Friday, on March 20th, Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky's new show is coming out. You remember these guys. They wrote on the office for many, many years. They wrote dinner party. They wrote dinner party. They also played Leo and Gino. Yes. They've been on the podcast. Well, you might remember a few years ago,
Yeah. That's my number one, I think. All right. Well, now we have some news from our office universe. This Friday, on March 20th, Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky's new show is coming out. You remember these guys. They wrote on the office for many, many years. They wrote dinner party. They wrote dinner party. They also played Leo and Gino. Yes. They've been on the podcast. Well, you might remember a few years ago,|||Yeah. That's my number one, I think. All right. Well, now we have some news from our office universe. This Friday, on March 20th, Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stepnitsky's new show is coming out. You remember these guys. They wrote on the office for many, many years. They wrote dinner party. They wrote dinner party. They also played Leo and Gino. Yes. They've been on the podcast. Well, you might remember a few years ago,
they had that amazing show, jury duty. It was a fake documentary about a trial where everybody was an actor except one person was real. Right. And he wasn't in on it. Everyone else was in on it. He thought it was a real trial happening. Yes. It was amazing.
they had that amazing show, jury duty. It was a fake documentary about a trial where everybody was an actor except one person was real. Right. And he wasn't in on it. Everyone else was in on it. He thought it was a real trial happening. Yes. It was amazing.|||they had that amazing show, jury duty. It was a fake documentary about a trial where everybody was an actor except one person was real. Right. And he wasn't in on it. Everyone else was in on it. He thought it was a real trial happening. Yes. It was amazing.
Critically acclaimed. Well, they have a season two and a new concept, and it is absolutely brilliant. It's brilliant. Lee sent Jen and I, the trailer, and it is hilarious. I'm already hooked. It's called Company Retreat, and the new premise is that cameras are following this newly hired employee at a small business. And shortly after he gets hired, the whole company is going to go on a company retreat. Yes. And everyone at the business is an actor except for the new employee.
Critically acclaimed. Well, they have a season two and a new concept, and it is absolutely brilliant. It's brilliant. Lee sent Jen and I, the trailer, and it is hilarious. I'm already hooked. It's called Company Retreat, and the new premise is that cameras are following this newly hired employee at a small business. And shortly after he gets hired, the whole company is going to go on a company retreat. Yes. And everyone at the business is an actor except for the new employee.|||Critically acclaimed. Well, they have a season two and a new concept, and it is absolutely brilliant. It's brilliant. Lee sent Jen and I, the trailer, and it is hilarious. I'm already hooked. It's called Company Retreat, and the new premise is that cameras are following this newly hired employee at a small business. And shortly after he gets hired, the whole company is going to go on a company retreat. Yes. And everyone at the business is an actor except for the new employee.
You guys, I wrote Lee and I was like, this is brilliant. I feel like this is what it would be like if you could go be transported into an episode of the office. Exactly. Like if you were the new employee and you had to go to beach games. Yes, exactly. And that's like part of your first week of work. But one of the brilliant things about it is the owner of the business is about to turn the business over to his son. And the son is just like full hot nepo baby.
You guys, I wrote Lee and I was like, this is brilliant. I feel like this is what it would be like if you could go be transported into an episode of the office. Exactly. Like if you were the new employee and you had to go to beach games. Yes, exactly. And that's like part of your first week of work. But one of the brilliant things about it is the owner of the business is about to turn the business over to his son. And the son is just like full hot nepo baby.|||You guys, I wrote Lee and I was like, this is brilliant. I feel like this is what it would be like if you could go be transported into an episode of the office. Exactly. Like if you were the new employee and you had to go to beach games. Yes, exactly. And that's like part of your first week of work. But one of the brilliant things about it is the owner of the business is about to turn the business over to his son. And the son is just like full hot nepo baby.
Yes. Hot mess. Hilarious. But then as the company retreat unfolds, you see all the different personalities of the coworkers because they have to do these ridiculous exercises. like walk on the hot coals, that type of stuff, right? Yes. Not to go back to beach games, but I couldn't help but think of that episode as I watched the trailer.
Yes. Hot mess. Hilarious. But then as the company retreat unfolds, you see all the different personalities of the coworkers because they have to do these ridiculous exercises. like walk on the hot coals, that type of stuff, right? Yes. Not to go back to beach games, but I couldn't help but think of that episode as I watched the trailer.|||Yes. Hot mess. Hilarious. But then as the company retreat unfolds, you see all the different personalities of the coworkers because they have to do these ridiculous exercises. like walk on the hot coals, that type of stuff, right? Yes. Not to go back to beach games, but I couldn't help but think of that episode as I watched the trailer.
I'm sure it's going to be amazing. Jury Duty was amazing. No, it's going to be a big hit. I can't wait to watch it. So we just want to wish them. Congratulations. Everybody, you can check it out. The first three episodes debut this Friday, March 20th on Prime Video.
I'm sure it's going to be amazing. Jury Duty was amazing. No, it's going to be a big hit. I can't wait to watch it. So we just want to wish them. Congratulations. Everybody, you can check it out. The first three episodes debut this Friday, March 20th on Prime Video.|||I'm sure it's going to be amazing. Jury Duty was amazing. No, it's going to be a big hit. I can't wait to watch it. So we just want to wish them. Congratulations. Everybody, you can check it out. The first three episodes debut this Friday, March 20th on Prime Video.
Congrats, Lee and Jean. We love you guys. Well, not on the same level, but Jenna and I actually just had art. very own company retreat. We did. It was a two-person company retreat. It was just me and Jenna, we went to a hotel about, I don't know, like 40 minutes away. Yep. And we brought our laptops and we just worked and worked office ladies. And it was so fun because we also have BFF time. Yeah. Mixed in with all that. And we have decided a bunch of fun stuff. But what I want to share today, which is we want to really start hearing from you guys during our second
Congrats, Lee and Jean. We love you guys. Well, not on the same level, but Jenna and I actually just had art. very own company retreat. We did. It was a two-person company retreat. It was just me and Jenna, we went to a hotel about, I don't know, like 40 minutes away. Yep. And we brought our laptops and we just worked and worked office ladies. And it was so fun because we also have BFF time. Yeah. Mixed in with all that. And we have decided a bunch of fun stuff. But what I want to share today, which is we want to really start hearing from you guys during our second|||Congrats, Lee and Jean. We love you guys. Well, not on the same level, but Jenna and I actually just had art. very own company retreat. We did. It was a two-person company retreat. It was just me and Jenna, we went to a hotel about, I don't know, like 40 minutes away. Yep. And we brought our laptops and we just worked and worked office ladies. And it was so fun because we also have BFF time. Yeah. Mixed in with all that. And we have decided a bunch of fun stuff. But what I want to share today, which is we want to really start hearing from you guys during our second
drinks. Yeah. You know, so many of you write in and you will tell us a favorite moment, a favorite scene, and we thought what a better way to feature those than in our second drinks. We're going to call them fan favorite moments. We'll put up some folders as our episodes roll out. Please write in and tell us your favorite scene from these upcoming episodes. So be on the lookout. We're going to give you prompts in our Insta stories for whatever episodes are coming out, but we would love to hear your favorite scenes and we're going to talk about them. You know, ladies, we've just been incorporating all these ways that we get to hear from people now with the fan chit-chats and the around-the-towns. And I really like it. I feel like it was really inspired from your trip to the office convention when we got to hear all the audio from people.
drinks. Yeah. You know, so many of you write in and you will tell us a favorite moment, a favorite scene, and we thought what a better way to feature those than in our second drinks. We're going to call them fan favorite moments. We'll put up some folders as our episodes roll out. Please write in and tell us your favorite scene from these upcoming episodes. So be on the lookout. We're going to give you prompts in our Insta stories for whatever episodes are coming out, but we would love to hear your favorite scenes and we're going to talk about them. You know, ladies, we've just been incorporating all these ways that we get to hear from people now with the fan chit-chats and the around-the-towns. And I really like it. I feel like it was really inspired from your trip to the office convention when we got to hear all the audio from people.|||drinks. Yeah. You know, so many of you write in and you will tell us a favorite moment, a favorite scene, and we thought what a better way to feature those than in our second drinks. We're going to call them fan favorite moments. We'll put up some folders as our episodes roll out. Please write in and tell us your favorite scene from these upcoming episodes. So be on the lookout. We're going to give you prompts in our Insta stories for whatever episodes are coming out, but we would love to hear your favorite scenes and we're going to talk about them. You know, ladies, we've just been incorporating all these ways that we get to hear from people now with the fan chit-chats and the around-the-towns. And I really like it. I feel like it was really inspired from your trip to the office convention when we got to hear all the audio from people.
And when I was recording people at the stage door in Chicago. And we talked about it. We were like, we like this. Yes. And then I think the other thing that happened is we found out that we could get audio clips on our website. Yes, that you can upload them. Yeah, that was a game changer. Shout out to Squarespace. Sorry, it took us so long, you guys, to get caught up with that technology, but we really love hearing from you and can't wait to hear your favorite moments from upcoming second drinks.
And when I was recording people at the stage door in Chicago. And we talked about it. We were like, we like this. Yes. And then I think the other thing that happened is we found out that we could get audio clips on our website. Yes, that you can upload them. Yeah, that was a game changer. Shout out to Squarespace. Sorry, it took us so long, you guys, to get caught up with that technology, but we really love hearing from you and can't wait to hear your favorite moments from upcoming second drinks.|||And when I was recording people at the stage door in Chicago. And we talked about it. We were like, we like this. Yes. And then I think the other thing that happened is we found out that we could get audio clips on our website. Yes, that you can upload them. Yeah, that was a game changer. Shout out to Squarespace. Sorry, it took us so long, you guys, to get caught up with that technology, but we really love hearing from you and can't wait to hear your favorite moments from upcoming second drinks.
We also have a couple of social media updates for you. First of all, I want you to know that I have updated our links in bio. Way to go. On Instagram. Angela, you handle all the posting, but my job is. the links in bio. So I'm going to do better, everybody. These links will be more extensive and take you places you want to go. So I just want to put that out there. Very proud of you. Thank you. And the other thing we're excited to share with you is that we have partnered again with Cartooner
We also have a couple of social media updates for you. First of all, I want you to know that I have updated our links in bio. Way to go. On Instagram. Angela, you handle all the posting, but my job is. the links in bio. So I'm going to do better, everybody. These links will be more extensive and take you places you want to go. So I just want to put that out there. Very proud of you. Thank you. And the other thing we're excited to share with you is that we have partnered again with Cartooner|||We also have a couple of social media updates for you. First of all, I want you to know that I have updated our links in bio. Way to go. On Instagram. Angela, you handle all the posting, but my job is. the links in bio. So I'm going to do better, everybody. These links will be more extensive and take you places you want to go. So I just want to put that out there. Very proud of you. Thank you. And the other thing we're excited to share with you is that we have partnered again with Cartooner
Radio. You know, they do amazing animation of podcasts. And they are going to do the first six episodes from season one of our rewatch of the office. And they're going to do sort of like the high lights of things that we talked about. And they're so fun. They're up on our YouTube page, our Office Ladies YouTube page, and you can watch them. And we hope you like them. Yeah, the cool thing about it is that we were able to add our personal photos. So it's like a 10-minute highlight of each episode. But like, for example, in the pilot, we flash up all of our personal photos from the pilot. And Angela, I have to share something. So when we were looking for what to share visually from Diversity Day. We talk a little bit about like how great the script
Radio. You know, they do amazing animation of podcasts. And they are going to do the first six episodes from season one of our rewatch of the office. And they're going to do sort of like the high lights of things that we talked about. And they're so fun. They're up on our YouTube page, our Office Ladies YouTube page, and you can watch them. And we hope you like them. Yeah, the cool thing about it is that we were able to add our personal photos. So it's like a 10-minute highlight of each episode. But like, for example, in the pilot, we flash up all of our personal photos from the pilot. And Angela, I have to share something. So when we were looking for what to share visually from Diversity Day. We talk a little bit about like how great the script|||Radio. You know, they do amazing animation of podcasts. And they are going to do the first six episodes from season one of our rewatch of the office. And they're going to do sort of like the high lights of things that we talked about. And they're so fun. They're up on our YouTube page, our Office Ladies YouTube page, and you can watch them. And we hope you like them. Yeah, the cool thing about it is that we were able to add our personal photos. So it's like a 10-minute highlight of each episode. But like, for example, in the pilot, we flash up all of our personal photos from the pilot. And Angela, I have to share something. So when we were looking for what to share visually from Diversity Day. We talk a little bit about like how great the script
was and how I still have my script. And so I thought, oh, I know, I'll take a picture of my script from Diversity Day so we can flash it up in this video. Right. So I went digging for it. And first of all, my script from Diversity Day is on blue paper. Oh, so that was the second version. Yes, I was going to explain, that's how they would distinguish the different drafts of a script. So first, they would give it to us on white paper. And then they would either give you a whole new printout on blue paper or if there were just a few changes, they'd just give you blue pages. Right. And then it was your job to go in and take out the white page and put in the blue page for the rewrite. And then the third draft would be pink pages. And then I think it was like yellow, green. And then I feel like it went back to white.
was and how I still have my script. And so I thought, oh, I know, I'll take a picture of my script from Diversity Day so we can flash it up in this video. Right. So I went digging for it. And first of all, my script from Diversity Day is on blue paper. Oh, so that was the second version. Yes, I was going to explain, that's how they would distinguish the different drafts of a script. So first, they would give it to us on white paper. And then they would either give you a whole new printout on blue paper or if there were just a few changes, they'd just give you blue pages. Right. And then it was your job to go in and take out the white page and put in the blue page for the rewrite. And then the third draft would be pink pages. And then I think it was like yellow, green. And then I feel like it went back to white.|||was and how I still have my script. And so I thought, oh, I know, I'll take a picture of my script from Diversity Day so we can flash it up in this video. Right. So I went digging for it. And first of all, my script from Diversity Day is on blue paper. Oh, so that was the second version. Yes, I was going to explain, that's how they would distinguish the different drafts of a script. So first, they would give it to us on white paper. And then they would either give you a whole new printout on blue paper or if there were just a few changes, they'd just give you blue pages. Right. And then it was your job to go in and take out the white page and put in the blue page for the rewrite. And then the third draft would be pink pages. And then I think it was like yellow, green. And then I feel like it went back to white.
No, I think every once while we got to orange, but that was very rare. Yeah. And those were usually loose pages. Yes. They weren't the whole script. But sometimes by the end of the week, you'd have like this multi-colored script. Well, anyway, this script was all blue. So I guess they did one big rewrite and they printed it out on blue.
No, I think every once while we got to orange, but that was very rare. Yeah. And those were usually loose pages. Yes. They weren't the whole script. But sometimes by the end of the week, you'd have like this multi-colored script. Well, anyway, this script was all blue. So I guess they did one big rewrite and they printed it out on blue.|||No, I think every once while we got to orange, but that was very rare. Yeah. And those were usually loose pages. Yes. They weren't the whole script. But sometimes by the end of the week, you'd have like this multi-colored script. Well, anyway, this script was all blue. So I guess they did one big rewrite and they printed it out on blue.
I don't have any other color pages. However, at the very end of my script, I have five white pages. You guys, I want you to know Jenna brought. her script in. She's holding it. I'm looking at it. And what did you write on the front of it? Did you write Pam? Pam. I wrote Pam. So everyone knows that's your script. That's so cute. Well, that was a thing back then. Like, if you didn't put your name on it, anyone might pick it up. It's true. Well, I was like, what are the white pages at the end? Do you know what it is, lady?
I don't have any other color pages. However, at the very end of my script, I have five white pages. You guys, I want you to know Jenna brought. her script in. She's holding it. I'm looking at it. And what did you write on the front of it? Did you write Pam? Pam. I wrote Pam. So everyone knows that's your script. That's so cute. Well, that was a thing back then. Like, if you didn't put your name on it, anyone might pick it up. It's true. Well, I was like, what are the white pages at the end? Do you know what it is, lady?|||I don't have any other color pages. However, at the very end of my script, I have five white pages. You guys, I want you to know Jenna brought. her script in. She's holding it. I'm looking at it. And what did you write on the front of it? Did you write Pam? Pam. I wrote Pam. So everyone knows that's your script. That's so cute. Well, that was a thing back then. Like, if you didn't put your name on it, anyone might pick it up. It's true. Well, I was like, what are the white pages at the end? Do you know what it is, lady?
No, what is it? It's my Pam document. I printed it out. I three-hole punched it. and I attached it to the back of my script. And I remember I did that for season one of the office. Lady, your theater nerd heart is so wonderful. And I'm so excited I found this because I couldn't find it on my computer. So this is now the only copy I have is this hard copy that I printed and attached to the back of my Diversity Day script. And I have to read you something from it. I want to hear all of it.
No, what is it? It's my Pam document. I printed it out. I three-hole punched it. and I attached it to the back of my script. And I remember I did that for season one of the office. Lady, your theater nerd heart is so wonderful. And I'm so excited I found this because I couldn't find it on my computer. So this is now the only copy I have is this hard copy that I printed and attached to the back of my Diversity Day script. And I have to read you something from it. I want to hear all of it.|||No, what is it? It's my Pam document. I printed it out. I three-hole punched it. and I attached it to the back of my script. And I remember I did that for season one of the office. Lady, your theater nerd heart is so wonderful. And I'm so excited I found this because I couldn't find it on my computer. So this is now the only copy I have is this hard copy that I printed and attached to the back of my Diversity Day script. And I have to read you something from it. I want to hear all of it.
I mean, I wish I had this for all about Pam Beasley. Oh. But here we go. I have this section where I'm really trying to figure out Pam and Roy's relationship. And so I wrote this prompt, what was your biggest fight? I wrote, our biggest fight ever was the time that I told him that if I found out that he committed a murder, that I would turn him into the police. Like, if they didn't know who did it and he wasn't. planning to turn himself in. He got really, really mad and said that families are supposed to
I mean, I wish I had this for all about Pam Beasley. Oh. But here we go. I have this section where I'm really trying to figure out Pam and Roy's relationship. And so I wrote this prompt, what was your biggest fight? I wrote, our biggest fight ever was the time that I told him that if I found out that he committed a murder, that I would turn him into the police. Like, if they didn't know who did it and he wasn't. planning to turn himself in. He got really, really mad and said that families are supposed to|||I mean, I wish I had this for all about Pam Beasley. Oh. But here we go. I have this section where I'm really trying to figure out Pam and Roy's relationship. And so I wrote this prompt, what was your biggest fight? I wrote, our biggest fight ever was the time that I told him that if I found out that he committed a murder, that I would turn him into the police. Like, if they didn't know who did it and he wasn't. planning to turn himself in. He got really, really mad and said that families are supposed to
protect each other. And I said, yeah, but not from murder. He said, what if he was really, really sorry? And I could tell that he would never murder someone again. I don't know. I still think I'd probably turn him in. That's amazing. Yeah. That's amazing. And it's such like one of those hypothetical bullshit things that you get in a fight about because the real things aren't working. Yeah. So you don't talk about the real things and then you have all of this pent up stuff about a hypothetical. Well, I think it kind of touched on a type of disconnect in their like fundamental values, you know? Yeah. Like Roy values family loyalty over everything. And Pam sort of is a rule follower.
protect each other. And I said, yeah, but not from murder. He said, what if he was really, really sorry? And I could tell that he would never murder someone again. I don't know. I still think I'd probably turn him in. That's amazing. Yeah. That's amazing. And it's such like one of those hypothetical bullshit things that you get in a fight about because the real things aren't working. Yeah. So you don't talk about the real things and then you have all of this pent up stuff about a hypothetical. Well, I think it kind of touched on a type of disconnect in their like fundamental values, you know? Yeah. Like Roy values family loyalty over everything. And Pam sort of is a rule follower.|||protect each other. And I said, yeah, but not from murder. He said, what if he was really, really sorry? And I could tell that he would never murder someone again. I don't know. I still think I'd probably turn him in. That's amazing. Yeah. That's amazing. And it's such like one of those hypothetical bullshit things that you get in a fight about because the real things aren't working. Yeah. So you don't talk about the real things and then you have all of this pent up stuff about a hypothetical. Well, I think it kind of touched on a type of disconnect in their like fundamental values, you know? Yeah. Like Roy values family loyalty over everything. And Pam sort of is a rule follower.
And feels like she has a sort of moral obligation to the world that sometimes could supersede the family. Yes. I was like, that's really interesting. I also wrote, I used to be an illustrator, but Roy told me it was time for us to get regular jobs. I used to just be a receptionist on the side while I drew and tried to get work as an illustrator. I'm artistic, but I've given it up to have a more stable life and job. That is great. Because for me, that fills in that question of like, why is Pam there? Why is she the receptionist? Why does she seem so beat down in this job on top of everything else?
And feels like she has a sort of moral obligation to the world that sometimes could supersede the family. Yes. I was like, that's really interesting. I also wrote, I used to be an illustrator, but Roy told me it was time for us to get regular jobs. I used to just be a receptionist on the side while I drew and tried to get work as an illustrator. I'm artistic, but I've given it up to have a more stable life and job. That is great. Because for me, that fills in that question of like, why is Pam there? Why is she the receptionist? Why does she seem so beat down in this job on top of everything else?|||And feels like she has a sort of moral obligation to the world that sometimes could supersede the family. Yes. I was like, that's really interesting. I also wrote, I used to be an illustrator, but Roy told me it was time for us to get regular jobs. I used to just be a receptionist on the side while I drew and tried to get work as an illustrator. I'm artistic, but I've given it up to have a more stable life and job. That is great. Because for me, that fills in that question of like, why is Pam there? Why is she the receptionist? Why does she seem so beat down in this job on top of everything else?
It seems like a real step back for her, just being there. Yeah. I felt like I needed to answer those questions for myself when I started the job. Theater students out there. How about that background work, building your character, things people don't ever see. It's true. Well, thank you very much to Cartuna for asking us to dig around in our personal photos because now I have my Pam document back. And you guys, I'll share in our stories where you can find our animated highlights of the first six episodes of Office Ladies. And you can also find
It seems like a real step back for her, just being there. Yeah. I felt like I needed to answer those questions for myself when I started the job. Theater students out there. How about that background work, building your character, things people don't ever see. It's true. Well, thank you very much to Cartuna for asking us to dig around in our personal photos because now I have my Pam document back. And you guys, I'll share in our stories where you can find our animated highlights of the first six episodes of Office Ladies. And you can also find|||It seems like a real step back for her, just being there. Yeah. I felt like I needed to answer those questions for myself when I started the job. Theater students out there. How about that background work, building your character, things people don't ever see. It's true. Well, thank you very much to Cartuna for asking us to dig around in our personal photos because now I have my Pam document back. And you guys, I'll share in our stories where you can find our animated highlights of the first six episodes of Office Ladies. And you can also find
them at the link in bio. Oh, yes, because Jenna's updated the link in bio. Yes, I have. All right, well, Angela, now I'm very excited. I'm going to turn it over to you. You watch the webisode blackmail. Yes, I did, and it is so delicious. It features Creed. First of all, I want you guys to know where you can find these. All of the webisodes are on Peacock, but they're labeled a little different. You have to go to the tile that says the office, like the original office, not the superfan versions. And then under that, you have to click on a little tab that says collections. And then under that, scroll down, and there's a little thing that says digital series. I don't want to get in their business, but I guess I do.
them at the link in bio. Oh, yes, because Jenna's updated the link in bio. Yes, I have. All right, well, Angela, now I'm very excited. I'm going to turn it over to you. You watch the webisode blackmail. Yes, I did, and it is so delicious. It features Creed. First of all, I want you guys to know where you can find these. All of the webisodes are on Peacock, but they're labeled a little different. You have to go to the tile that says the office, like the original office, not the superfan versions. And then under that, you have to click on a little tab that says collections. And then under that, scroll down, and there's a little thing that says digital series. I don't want to get in their business, but I guess I do.|||them at the link in bio. Oh, yes, because Jenna's updated the link in bio. Yes, I have. All right, well, Angela, now I'm very excited. I'm going to turn it over to you. You watch the webisode blackmail. Yes, I did, and it is so delicious. It features Creed. First of all, I want you guys to know where you can find these. All of the webisodes are on Peacock, but they're labeled a little different. You have to go to the tile that says the office, like the original office, not the superfan versions. And then under that, you have to click on a little tab that says collections. And then under that, scroll down, and there's a little thing that says digital series. I don't want to get in their business, but I guess I do.
Why are you making it so hard to find these? Yeah, you do have to dig. And also, we always called them webisodes. So I guess they call them digital series. But that's where they live and there's a bunch of them and they're fantastic. And today I want to highlight blackmail. It is a series of four, around two-minute clips and you just watch them all in a row. clip one reveals Creed has decided to blackmail his co-workers. The first person he's going to
Why are you making it so hard to find these? Yeah, you do have to dig. And also, we always called them webisodes. So I guess they call them digital series. But that's where they live and there's a bunch of them and they're fantastic. And today I want to highlight blackmail. It is a series of four, around two-minute clips and you just watch them all in a row. clip one reveals Creed has decided to blackmail his co-workers. The first person he's going to|||Why are you making it so hard to find these? Yeah, you do have to dig. And also, we always called them webisodes. So I guess they call them digital series. But that's where they live and there's a bunch of them and they're fantastic. And today I want to highlight blackmail. It is a series of four, around two-minute clips and you just watch them all in a row. clip one reveals Creed has decided to blackmail his co-workers. The first person he's going to
try to blackmail is Oscar. So the opening scene is Oscar watching a video on a laptop of Creed, and then Creed walks in behind him in real time. It's all in the conference room. I want you guys to hear it. If you're watching this video, you've been a very naughty person. I have learned some of your deepest, darkest secrets. And with this not... I have the ability to ruin your world. But it needn't come to that. It's possible I could forget a thing or two. If you're willing to compensate me, I'm 100% serious.
try to blackmail is Oscar. So the opening scene is Oscar watching a video on a laptop of Creed, and then Creed walks in behind him in real time. It's all in the conference room. I want you guys to hear it. If you're watching this video, you've been a very naughty person. I have learned some of your deepest, darkest secrets. And with this not... I have the ability to ruin your world. But it needn't come to that. It's possible I could forget a thing or two. If you're willing to compensate me, I'm 100% serious.|||try to blackmail is Oscar. So the opening scene is Oscar watching a video on a laptop of Creed, and then Creed walks in behind him in real time. It's all in the conference room. I want you guys to hear it. If you're watching this video, you've been a very naughty person. I have learned some of your deepest, darkest secrets. And with this not... I have the ability to ruin your world. But it needn't come to that. It's possible I could forget a thing or two. If you're willing to compensate me, I'm 100% serious.
Pay me now, or I will share this with the world. Are my eyes blue? Are you trying to blackmail me? Blackmail is an ugly word. I prefer extortion. Why are you doing this? How much will you pay me to find out? Creed, this is low. Easy on the sass.
Pay me now, or I will share this with the world. Are my eyes blue? Are you trying to blackmail me? Blackmail is an ugly word. I prefer extortion. Why are you doing this? How much will you pay me to find out? Creed, this is low. Easy on the sass.|||Pay me now, or I will share this with the world. Are my eyes blue? Are you trying to blackmail me? Blackmail is an ugly word. I prefer extortion. Why are you doing this? How much will you pay me to find out? Creed, this is low. Easy on the sass.
We're just two amigos having a guess. two amigos having a conversation, Comprehended. All right. Let's switch back to English for a second. Just spit it out. What do you have on me? So, first of all,
We're just two amigos having a guess. two amigos having a conversation, Comprehended. All right. Let's switch back to English for a second. Just spit it out. What do you have on me? So, first of all,|||We're just two amigos having a guess. two amigos having a conversation, Comprehended. All right. Let's switch back to English for a second. Just spit it out. What do you have on me? So, first of all,
Creed saying easy on the SaaS made my whole day. But what we find out that Creed has on Oscar is a video of Oscar getting picked up from work by his boyfriend. It's so uninteresting.
Creed saying easy on the SaaS made my whole day. But what we find out that Creed has on Oscar is a video of Oscar getting picked up from work by his boyfriend. It's so uninteresting.|||Creed saying easy on the SaaS made my whole day. But what we find out that Creed has on Oscar is a video of Oscar getting picked up from work by his boyfriend. It's so uninteresting.
It's so normal. And Oscar just dismisses it and leaves. So now Creed has to move on to someone else. Well, everybody already knows about Oscar and Gill. I mean, remember after Gay Witch Hunt, they get to leave on like a 12-week vacation paid for by the company. Right.
It's so normal. And Oscar just dismisses it and leaves. So now Creed has to move on to someone else. Well, everybody already knows about Oscar and Gill. I mean, remember after Gay Witch Hunt, they get to leave on like a 12-week vacation paid for by the company. Right.|||It's so normal. And Oscar just dismisses it and leaves. So now Creed has to move on to someone else. Well, everybody already knows about Oscar and Gill. I mean, remember after Gay Witch Hunt, they get to leave on like a 12-week vacation paid for by the company. Right.
So this isn't news, Creed. Exactly. And Oscar just dismisses it. Yeah. So now he's got to move on to Andy. And he hands Andy this green envelope. Andy takes a look inside and completely is thrown. He is shaken by whatever is inside this green envelope.
So this isn't news, Creed. Exactly. And Oscar just dismisses it. Yeah. So now he's got to move on to Andy. And he hands Andy this green envelope. Andy takes a look inside and completely is thrown. He is shaken by whatever is inside this green envelope.|||So this isn't news, Creed. Exactly. And Oscar just dismisses it. Yeah. So now he's got to move on to Andy. And he hands Andy this green envelope. Andy takes a look inside and completely is thrown. He is shaken by whatever is inside this green envelope.
That is sort of the cliffhanger that takes you to clip two. Clip two starts with Andy freaking out. Creed has given him an ultimatum, and he clearly has some good dirt on him. But Andy says, I don't know what to do yet. And then we learn a tough decision that Andy had to make in the past. Let's hear it. I'm freaking out. And I haven't freaked out about a decision like this since I had to choose between here comes treble.
That is sort of the cliffhanger that takes you to clip two. Clip two starts with Andy freaking out. Creed has given him an ultimatum, and he clearly has some good dirt on him. But Andy says, I don't know what to do yet. And then we learn a tough decision that Andy had to make in the past. Let's hear it. I'm freaking out. And I haven't freaked out about a decision like this since I had to choose between here comes treble.|||That is sort of the cliffhanger that takes you to clip two. Clip two starts with Andy freaking out. Creed has given him an ultimatum, and he clearly has some good dirt on him. But Andy says, I don't know what to do yet. And then we learn a tough decision that Andy had to make in the past. Let's hear it. I'm freaking out. And I haven't freaked out about a decision like this since I had to choose between here comes treble.
travel in paradise, the troubleshooters, and the Finger Lake Maestro's. That was his decision. He had to pick between these acapella groups. And I just think about our writers sitting there pitching different names for acapella groups, and they're all so amazing. You know they spent way too many hours on those name pitches. Oh, yeah. I bet there's a ton more that we didn't even get to hear. So anyway, Crete is going to keep pressuring Andy, and then Andy just decides he's got to take matter of. into his own hands, and he is going to make this huge announcement to the bullpen about what Creed has on him. Any guesses, lady? I can't think of anything. I was not prepared for this.
travel in paradise、the troubleshooters 以及 the Finger Lake Maestro's。那是他的决定。他必须在这些无伴奏合唱团中做出选择。我就会想到我们的编剧们坐在那里，为无伴奏合唱团构思不同的名字，它们都太棒了。你知道他们在这些名字上花了太多时间。哦，是的。我敢说还有更多我们甚至都没听到的。不管怎样，克里德将继续给安迪施压，然后安迪决定必须亲自解决这件事，他要在办公区发表一个重大声明，关于克里德掌握了他什么把柄。有什么猜测吗，女士？我想不出什么。我对此毫无准备。
He lifts up his shirt to show everyone he has a tattoo on his lower back. And it looks like it's written in sort of a different language. And he shares that it means nard dog. Kelly starts teasing him, says he has a tramp stamp. And Andy says he doesn't regret it, but he is how he has. having it lasered off. So lady, Andy, this is his other tattoo? Because he had Nard Dog. Well, he gets Nard Dog. Exactly. So is this webisode between now and when he gets Nard Dog? It's got to be, but it's just hilarious to me that Andy has such mishaps with tattoos. Well, this is his snip, snap, snip, snip moment then. He had a Nard Dog tattoo that he got lasered off and then he went and got another nard dog tattoo. Exactly. But remember that trend where people
他掀起衬衫，向大家展示他下背部有一个纹身。看起来像是用某种不同的语言写的。他分享说这意味着“Nard Dog”（纳德狗）。凯利开始取笑他，说他有一个“荡妇印记”（tramp stamp）。安迪说他不后悔，但他正在把它用激光去除。所以女士，安迪，这是他的另一个纹身吗？因为他有“Nard Dog”。嗯，他身上有“Nard Dog”。没错。那么这个网络剧集发生在现在和他在身上纹“Nard Dog”之间吗？肯定是这样，但对我来说太搞笑的是，安迪在纹身上总是状况百出。好吧，这就是他的“剪、咔嚓、剪、咔嚓”时刻了。他有一个“Nard Dog”纹身，用激光去掉了，然后又去弄了另一个“Nard Dog”纹身。没错。但记得那个潮流吗？人们
would get different sayings or messages in like a different language? I don't know the tattoo trends. What? Sam, are you there? This was, I remember in my improv days, there would be like some dude with like some type of character type writing on their arm and it would mean like truth. That and tribal tattoo goes in and out of popularity every decade. Yeah. Yeah. Do you remember the armband? tattoo that Pamela Anderson got, the barbed wire. Yes. Those are in style again, by the way. Are they back?
会在身上纹不同语言的格言或寄语？我不懂纹身潮流。什么？萨姆，你在吗？这是，我记得在我即兴表演的日子里，会有那种家伙，手臂上有什么特殊字符的字体，意思是“真理”。这种还有部落纹身每十年就会流行一阵又退流行。是啊。是啊。你还记得帕梅拉·安德森纹的那种臂环纹身吗，带刺铁丝网。记得。顺便说一句，那些又开始流行了。又回来了吗？
Yep. I always liked those. That and tramp stamps are officially back. Tramp stamps are back. Well, Andy had one in a language. She wasn't really sure what it was, but it said Nard Dog. That's the thing. I always was like, if it's not the language you speak and you don't speak that language,
对啊。我一直挺喜欢那些的。那东西和“荡妇印记”正式回归了。“荡妇印记”又回来了。好吧，安迪身上有一种语言的纹身。她其实不太确定那是什么，但上面写着“Nard Dog”。就是这样。我总是觉得，如果这不是你说的语言，而且你也不会说那种语言，
how do you know? How do you know what's getting tattooed on you? Yep. You got to really trust your tattoo artist. Yeah, you do. You guys, I have a story of a famous guy. I'm not going to say who it is. Oh, come on.
你怎么知道？你怎么知道自己身上纹的是什么？没错。你真的得信任你的纹身师。是的，必须的。伙计们，我有一个关于某个名人的故事。我不说是谁。哦，别这样。
But only because he would tell this story. If we had him on our podcast, he would tell this story. Okay. But I was working on a project with him, and he wanted to get a tattoo. And he came to set, and he was, like, talking about what he wanted. And it was, like, a nautical thing. And he had other tattoos. So this wasn't his first.
但原因是他自己会讲这个故事。如果我们把他请到播客里，他会讲这个故事。好吧。但我当时正和他合作一个项目，他想去纹个身。他来到片场，一直在说他想要什么。这有点像航海风格的。他身上已经有其他纹身了。所以这不是他的第一次。
And he was kind of going over it. And then eventually he got it. And he came and he showed it to us. And it was nothing at all like what he had kind of been describing to us that he wanted. And it wasn't great. I'm going to also say like it's not that the tattoo work wasn't great, but the design. Where on his body was it? God, I think it was like on his biceps.
他一直在琢磨这事。然后最终他去纹了。他过来把纹身给我们看了。这跟他之前向我们描述的想要的完全不一样。而且不太好看。我也要说，倒不是说纹身手艺不好，而是设计本身。它在他身体的什么部位？天哪，我想大概在二头肌上吧。
Okay, good. Wait, Sam, why is that okay, good? I wanted to be visible and prominent. Visible and prominent. So, yeah, it was. Like, short-sleevee shirt. Good. Here it is.
好吧，不错。等等，萨姆，为什么说“好吧，不错”？我希望它是显眼且突出的。显眼且突出的。所以，是的，确实如此。穿着短袖衬衫。很好。就是这个。
Yep. Oh, my gosh. And we're all looking at it and none of us know how to react. And so we're all kind of like, huh? And he goes, I know. I know. And we're like, it's just different than what you said. He goes, I know.
是的。哦，天哪。我们都在看着它，谁也不知道该怎么反应。所以我们都有点像，呃？然后他说，我知道。我知道。我们就像，这跟你说的完全不同。他说，我知道。
When I got there and he showed me the drawing, I didn't like it. What? But I felt bad, so I just let him do it. Tattooed on my body forever? Yeah. Because you felt bad? Because he was like, he didn't want. He didn't want to speak up.
我到那儿看到草图时，我就不喜欢它。什么？但我觉得不好意思，所以就让他们这么做了。永远纹在我的身体上？对啊。因为你觉得不好意思？因为他就像，他不想。他不想开口。
Yeah. He just, like, didn't want to disappoint the tattoo artist? Yeah. And then we were like, dude, It's on you forever. Yeah, you got to push back a little. And he was like, I know, I really regret not saying something. Oh, my gosh.
是啊。他只是不想让纹身师失望？是啊。然后我们就说，老兄，这会在你身上一辈子。是啊，你得稍微拒绝一下。然后他说，我知道，我真的很后悔当时没说点什么。哦，天哪。
What? And then we just teased him incessantly about it. I wonder if he ever got it lasered off. I don't think so. Did he pull an Andy? I couldn't ask him, I guess, but maybe he likes it now. I mean, maybe it grew on him. But you guys, it looks like something.
什么？然后我们就无休止地取笑他这件事。我想知道他后来有没有用激光去掉。我不觉得。他学了安迪吗？我想我没法问他，不过也许他现在喜欢上了。我是说，也许他慢慢习惯了。但是伙计们，它看起来就像
like a nautical logo on the menu of a fish restaurant. That's... That's sharkies in Redondo Beach. Something like that. Yeah. Something like that. Just super basic. Sure.
鱼类餐厅菜单上的航海标志。那是……那是雷东多海滩的 Sharkies。诸如此类的。对。差不多。就是超级基础的那种。当然。
I don't know how long it's been since you've spoken to this person, but if you did out of nowhere, let's say, text him and say, hey, remember that random nautical tattoo you got? Did you have it lasered off? I'll do it. Would you think it's odd and would he respond? I'll ask him. Oh my God, she's texting right now.
我不知道你跟这个人有多久没联系了，但如果你突然无缘无故地，比方说，发短信告诉他：“嘿，还记得你那个随机的航海纹身吗？你用激光洗掉了吗？”我会发。你觉得这会很奇怪吗，他会回复吗？我问问他。哦，天哪，她现在正在发短信。
I mean, this is super round. Let's see, the last time we texted was last October. Oh, that's not bad. Yeah. Okay. What is Jordan laughing about? I can hear Jordan laughing. I just said I wanted to be like Ben Affleck or somebody with that.
我是说，这太绝了。让我想想，我们上次发短信还是在去年十月。哦，那还不算太久。是啊。好的。乔丹在笑什么？我能听到乔丹在笑。我刚才是说我想变得像本·阿弗莱克或类似的人那样。
Does Ben Affleck still have that giant? Yes, on his back. It's real, right? It's a Phoenix, yeah, and it's bad. Nope. It's not what? I always thought that was for a movie. No, it's real.
本·阿弗莱克身上现在还留着那个巨大的……是的，在他的背上。那是真的，对吧？那是凤凰，对，而且很糟糕。不对。什么不是？我一直以为那是为了拍电影。不，那是真的。
And it is on there full time. And it's full color. Wow. And so, Sam, you've had tattoos. Like full color. That's a multi. That's multiple sessions. Yeah.
而且它是一直都在那儿的。还是全彩的。哇。所以，萨姆，你也有纹身。就像全彩的。那是多次。那是分好几次弄的。是啊。
Wow. And multiple thousands of dollars. Do you have any tattoos that you have soured on since you got them, Sam? Yes. I have the word truth written in Latin on my left arm. Oh my God. No, you don't. Sam, I'm telling you.
哇。而且要花好几千美元。萨姆，你有没有哪个纹身是你纹了之后就后悔了的？有的。我左臂上写着拉丁文的“真理”一词。哦，天哪。不，你没有。萨姆，我跟你说。
I'm telling you right now, there was a guy in my improv days that had truth on his forearm, written in like Mandarin. Well, this is an old thing. It's just, they just don't like the placement of it. It's blocking other bigger tattoos. Okay. That's amazing. Well, while we wait for Jenna's mysterious, famous person with the lame nautical
我现在就告诉你，我以前即兴表演时有个家伙前臂上有“真理”这个词，是用普通话写的。好吧，这是一件旧事。只是，他们只是不喜欢它的位置。它挡住了其他更大的纹身。好吧。太棒了。好吧，在我们等待詹娜那位带着糟糕航海纹身的神秘名人朋友给我们回信的同时，我们将继续进入“敲诈勒索”网络剧集的第三片段。现在克里德，安迪的那种大肆宣扬的声明起作用了。克里德不得不转向另一个人，那就是凯利。他递给凯利一个绿色的信封。凯利打开一看，是一张她亲吻一个女孩的照片。她完全无动于衷。她就像是，克里德，这是我的MySpace个人资料照片。而且她真的很喜欢这给她带来的关注。我在这里必须向《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的伙计们大声致谢，
tattoo to get back to us, we are going to move on now to clip three of the Blackmail Webisode series. Now Creed, Andy's sort of big announcement worked. Creed has to move on to someone else, and it's Kelly. He hands Kelly. green envelope. Kelly looks inside and it's a picture of her kissing a girl. She's completely unfazed. She's like, Creed, this is my MySpace profile picture. And she really loves the attention that's getting her. I have to give a shout out right here to the fellows on how we made your mother
因为他们跟我们分享说，他们在重温《办公室》时，很喜欢我们那些关于旧科技的梗。他们还加了一个。他们有一个叫“Old Ref”的词，就像是一个老梗。我觉得MySpace既是旧科技也是老梗。对的。所以克里德要再次对凯利下手了，因为他现在走投无路了。他说，好吧，行，我手里还有你的其他把柄。然后我们发现凯利为了去听强纳斯兄弟的演唱会而旷工。
because they shared with us that they love our old tech callouts during our rewatch of the office. and they have added one. They have one called Old Ref, which is like an old reference. And I think MySpace is both Old Tech and Old Ref. Yep. So Creed is going to try again with Kelly because he's desperate now. And he's like, all right, fine, I've got something else on you. And we find out that Kelly skipped work to go to a Jonas Brothers concert.
哦。然后凯利妥协了。她说，呃。接着克里德列出了他的要求。我们听听看。如果你想让我保持沉默，我需要你付出一点小小的代价。克里德，我不能失去工作。我有那么多的信用积分。我想要一架直升机。
Oh. And then Kelly Caves. She's like, ugh. And Creed lists off his demands. Let's hear them. And if you want me to be silent, I'm going to need a little something from you. Creed, I cannot lose my job. I have so much credit. I want a helicopter.
我买不起那个。好吧，那我想要大宗商品。我想要黄金、石油、政治资本、四叶草、骨头、情报、铀。你是说像事实这样的情报吗？不，像八卦。你想知道什么？我是说，凯利在八卦方面很擅长。是啊，好吧，现在他可以利用
I can't afford that. Well, then, I want commodities. I want gold, oil, political capital, four-leaf clovers, bones, information, uranium. Do you mean information like facts? No, like gossip. What do you want to know? I mean, Kelly can play ball on gossip. Yeah, well, now he can use.
她告诉他的事情去勒索更多的人。没错。镜头立刻切换到克里德，他走过整个办公区，左右分发着绿色的信封。他给安吉拉一个。然后他给梅雷迪思一个。梅雷迪思打开她的信封说：“吉姆牧师是谁？”然后克里德说：“哦，等一下。”然后他把那个抢回来递给安吉拉，安吉拉满脸通红。我知道。安吉拉和吉姆牧师有一腿吗？我们不知道。但那一刻也就到此为止了，因为接着奥斯卡说：“等等，我们得把这事处理好。”下一个片段是第四片段。所以奥斯卡挖出了很多关于克里德的料，他们在会议室里当面质问他。上面有一长串各种各样的事。其中有两件让我印象深刻，一是克里德把
use what she tells him to blackmail more people. Exactly. This cuts immediately to Creed, walking through the whole bullpen, passing out green envelopes left and right. He gives one to Angela. Then he gives one to Meredith. Meredith opens hers and says, who's Pastor Jim? And then Creed's like, oh, wait a second. And he grabs that one and hands it to Angela, and Angela's all flushed. I know. Did Angela hook up with Pastor Jim? We don't know. But that's as far as that moment goes, because then Oscar's like, wait, we've got to take care of this. Next clip is clip four. So Oscar has dug up a bunch of stuff on Creed, and they all confront him with it in the conference room. There's like a list of all sorts of stuff. Two that stood out for me was that Creed introduced
会走路的蛇头鱼引入了北美生态系统；二是据他可靠消息，克里德在仓库里举办锐舞派对，被派对狂热者称为“蓝精灵爸爸”（Papa Smurf）。萨姆，顺便问一下，如果在锐舞派对上被称为“蓝精灵爸爸”是什么意思？我不知道。我还以为这可能有什么含义呢。没有。这可能意味着你就像是……在我去锐舞派对和吸毒的这些年里，我从来没被贴上过“蓝精灵爸爸”的标签。
the walking snakehead fish to the North American ecosystem. And he has it on good authority that Creed throws raves in the warehouse and is known by party goers as Papa Smurf. What does that mean, Sam, by the way, if you're known as Papa Smurf at a rave? I don't know. I thought maybe it meant something. No. It could mean that you're like you give people like... In all my years of going to raves and doing drugs, I've never been labeled Papa Smurf.
我倒不认为你会被贴上标签，但我不知道在锐舞派对上是不是这样。听着，我对锐舞派对的全部了解都来自于《疾速追杀》电影。这就是你需要知道的全部。这就是全部的过程。那是刺客们去……在人群中穿梭的地方。是啊。是啊。
I didn't think you had been labeled, but I didn't know if at a rave. Listen, all I know about raves is from John Wick movies. That's all you need to know. That's all that's going on. It's where assassins go to like. Like run through the crowd. Yeah. Yeah.
不管怎样，最后，安迪说：“我们到底在干什么？”伙计们，他们看了看，发现克里德勒索他们的金额。有什么猜测吗？什么？没有。六美元。他想得到什么？等等，等等。
Anyway, ultimately, Andy is like, what are we doing? You guys, they look and see that the amount of money Crete is blackmailing them for. Any guesses? What? No. Six dollars. What does he want to get? Wait, wait.
他说六美元或者等值的邮票或罐头食品。然后安迪说，这让我有点不好意思。他显然很需要这六美元。所以他们所有人都妥协了，把钱给了克里德。结局是克里德超级高兴。他在用笔记本电脑。他的电脑上有一个画面。是一个玩具直升机。
He says $6 are the equivalent in postage stamps or canned goods. And Andy's like, this just kind of makes me feel bad. He clearly needs the $6. So they all just cave in and they give Creed the money. It ends with Creed super happy. He's at his laptop. And there's an image on his computer. It's a toy helicopter.
但克里德显然以为那是真的直升机。然后他拿着那六美元，伙计们，他把它塞进了软盘驱动器里。就像他以为这会把玩具吐出来一样。就像自动售货机一样。是的。他解释说他太兴奋了。他要开着他的新直升机去巴西看世界上最大的图书馆。哦。
But Creed clearly thinks it's a real helicopter. And he takes his $6 and, you guys, he shoves it into the floppy disk feet. Like he thinks it's going to spit out the toy. Like a vending machine. Yes. And he explains that he's so excited. He's going to fly his new helicopter to Brazil to see the world's largest library. Oh.
这就是《勒索》的结局。有一些精彩的场景我甚至都没提到，因为其中一些是视觉效果。它们太搞笑了。伙计们，我真的很推荐这个。看得很开心。好吧，那太精彩了，安吉拉。谢谢你给我们剖析这些。我只是觉得太有趣了。
And that is the end of blackmail. There are some great scenes that I didn't even get into because some of them are visuals. They're so funny. You guys, I really recommend this one. It's a fun watch. Well, that was delightful, Angela. Thank you for breaking that down for us. I just thought it was so fun.
我很喜欢拍摄这些网络剧集，通常只有精简的工作人员和我们一小群人在周末拍摄，我们只需要尽情玩耍。所以这有点勾起了我的回忆。好吧，我还没收到我那位名人朋友的回信。那我们为什么不休息一下呢？等我们回来，我们将有“走访小镇”和我们的“每周办公室提问”，可能还有关于这个纹身的答案。我们回来了。各位，依然没有我朋友的消息。
I loved filming these webisodes, and it was always just a skeleton crew and a group of us on the weekends, and we got to just play around. So it kind of brought me down memory lane. Well, I haven't heard back from my famous friend. So why don't we take a break? When we come back, we've got around the town and our office question of the week and maybe also an answer about this tattoo. We are back. Still no news from my friend, everybody.
抱歉让你们挂念了。但现在是时候了……我们的第一条消息来自安大略省斯特拉特福的米歇尔·G。米歇尔想让我们知道，斯特拉特福今年有很多活动。我们被评为加拿大十大旅游目的地之一。我们的厨师学校开设了有趣的课程供任何人参加。我们的剧院迎来了第73个年头。我们有巧克力之旅、烘焙、
Sorry to leave you hanging. But now it's time for... Our first bit of news is from Michelle G in Stratford, Ontario, Canada. Michelle wants us to know, Stratford has a lot going on this year. We have been named a top 10 list of places in Canada to visit. We have our chef school running fun courses for anyone to attend. Our theater is in its 73rd year. We have a chocolate tour, a baking.
培根和啤酒之旅以及自助语音导览。我们还在应对多年来最大的一场雪。好吧，米歇尔，我嫉妒你们所有的雪。我家里的滑雪爱好者一直在追逐雪。今年它不在任何寻常的地方。所以我想它落到你们那儿了。好吧，我只想去参加步行导览。我是说，培根和啤酒之旅？培根和啤酒。巧克力之旅？嗯哼。是的，拜托。
Aitin and Ail Tour and Audio Walking Tours. We are also dealing with the most snow that we have had in years. Well, Michelle, I'm jealous of all your snow. The skiers in my family have been chasing snow. It's not in any of the usual places this year. So I guess it's come to you. Well, I just want to go to the walking tours. I mean, a bacon and ale tour? Bacon and ale. Chocolate tour? Mm-hmm. Yes, please.
我知道。好的。我们的下一个“走访小镇”来自贝卡·B。贝卡说，每年在“全国金毛寻回犬日”前后，科罗拉多州的戈尔登市都会举办一个名为“金毛与戈尔登”的活动。成千上万——她用了全大写字母——成千上万的金毛寻回犬（或者是冒充的）和它们的主人聚集在一起，为所有的大好狗狗庆祝。这难道不是很可爱吗？金毛寻回犬日？是的。哦，天哪。我其实在Instagram上见过这种金毛寻回犬聚会，人们带着各自的金毛寻回犬聚在一起。我知道有几种不同的狗品种也这么做，但这实在是太可爱了。好吧。我查了一下。文章说，2月7日，超过5500只金毛寻回犬聚集在科罗拉多州戈尔登市，参加一年一度的“金毛与戈尔登”庆祝活动。哇。
I know. All right. Our next around the town is from Becca B. Becca says, every year around National Golden Retriever Day, Golden Colorado hosts an event called Goldens and Golden. Thousands, and she put that in all caps, thousands of golden retrievers or impostors and their owners gathered to celebrate all of the good boys. Isn't that adorable? Golden Retriever Day? Yes. Oh my gosh. I have actually seen on Instagram like these golden retriever gatherings where people all get together with their golden retrievers. I know there's several different dog breeds that do this, but it's pretty freaking adorable. All right. I looked this up. The article says over 5,500 in golden retrievers gathered in Golden Colorado on February 7th to enjoy the annual Goldens and Golden celebration. Wow.
我想去！我的朋友有一只金毛寻回犬，每当有一群金毛聚在一起时，比方说我们会去远足，然后它们都会互相打招呼。我不知道。伙计们，这实在是太可爱了。看起来它们都在笑。女士，你一定要发个帖子，因为我在看这篇文章，照片太不可思议了。是的，我在Instagram上看过。
I want to go! My friend has a golden retriever, and whenever, like, there's a group of them, like, we'll go on a hike, and then they all, like, say hi to each other. I don't know. It's just so cute, you guys. It looks like they smile. Lady, you have to post about this because I'm looking at this article, and the photos are incredible. Yeah, I've seen on Instagram.
简直太棒了。我们会在快拍里分享。这比你能想象的还要盛大。我是说，我知道我们抛出了数字，但当你看到所有人聚在一起时，你会想：天哪。好吧。那么，我们最后一个“走访小镇”来自堪萨斯城的娜塔莉·D，她说：我从13岁起就开始参加竞技保龄球。
It's just amazing. We'll share in our stories. It's way bigger than you could even imagine. I mean, I know we're throwing out numbers, but when you see everybody together, you're like, holy moly. All right. Well, our last bit of Around the Town comes from Natalie D in Kansas City, who said, I have been competitive bowling since I was 13 years old.
娜塔莉现在28岁了，上周终于打出了她的第一个300分满分局。娜塔莉，恭喜你。感谢《办公室女士》为去锦标赛漫长车程中的我们提供娱乐。这可是一件大事。这是一个巨大的成就。300分。我爷爷是个保龄球手，我记得他打出300分的时候。那太轰动了。
Natalie is now 28 and finally got her first 300 perfect game last week. Natalie, congratulations. Thanks to the office ladies for providing entertainment on long car rides to tournaments. That is a big deal. That is a big accomplishment. 300. My grandpa was a bowler, and I remember when he got his 300 game. It was huge.
感觉就像是一件天大的事。那是，多少个？连续12个全中（strike）？因为第10局有三个？对，我想是这样的。哇。干得好。太惊人了。娜塔莉，我的保龄球水平是：要么我走上去，慢吞吞地滚出一个球，慢慢击中球瓶，发出“啪”的声音，然后全中，每个人都说：“刚刚发生了什么？”要么我把球扔进沟里。只有这两种情况。这就是我的技能水平。太不可思议了。我知道。太惊人了。把我加入你们的团队吧。好的。接下来，各位，是我们的“每周办公室提问”。来自密歇根州的娜迪亚·H。娜迪亚说：你好，办公室女士们。我
It was like such a big deal. That is, how many? 12 strikes in a row? Because the 10th frame is three? Yeah, I think so. Wow. Well done. That is amazing. Natalie, my bowling is I either get up there and I just roll the slowest moving ball that hits the pins and it's like phe, and I get a strike and everyone's like, what just happened? Or I got her ball it. Those are the only two. That's my skill set. That's incredible. I know. It's pretty amazing. Sign me up for your team. All right. Up next, everybody, is our office. question of the week. This comes from Nadia H in Michigan. Nadia says, hello, office ladies. I have been
想给你们写信已经一年多了，我超级兴奋，现在终于赶上了播客的进度，可以跟你们分享你们俩对我有多重要。《办公室》是我最喜欢的节目。我拥有所有的DVD套装、大量的周边商品，甚至还有一个我每天晚上都用的《办公室》盖毯。你们俩真的是世界上最特别的人，非常感谢你们为《办公室女士》这个品牌付出的所有辛勤工作。哦，太甜了。娜迪亚接着说：我是一个神经多样性（neurodivergent）的人，生活在一个并不总是对像我这样的人友好或包容的世界里。有时这会非常艰难和让人不知所措，但每当我听你们的播客时，我都觉得自己被倾听、被看见，内心感到无比平静。我可以喋喋不休地讲你们俩对我有
wanting to write you all for over a year now, and I am beyond excited that I am now caught up with the podcast episodes and can share how much you two mean to me. The office is my favorite show. I own all of the DVD box sets, tons of merch, and I even have an office comforter that I use every night. You two are truly some of the most special people in the world, and thank you so much for all the hard work, that you put into the Office Ladies franchise. Aw, that's so sweet. Nadia goes on to say, I am a neurodivergent individual who lives in a world that is not always friendly or accepting of people like me. This can be very hard and overwhelming at times, but whenever I listen to your podcast, I feel so heard, seen, and just at peace. I could go on for ages about how much YouTube
多重要，但总而言之，我只是想让你们知道我有多爱你们俩。娜迪亚发来了一堆问题，我们今天要回答的其中一个问题是：你们看到自己的周边商品或壁纸上有自己的脸时，会觉得奇怪吗？她还说，P.S.安吉拉，我喜欢你的日记。这是我最喜欢的东西之一。娜迪亚，首先，我们要对所有这些暖心的话语表示感谢。是的。我甚至无法向你表达这个播客带给你的平静和安慰对意味着什么。是的。而且你感到被看见和被倾听，我们非常喜欢做这个播客，我们也真的深爱我们的办公室女士大家庭。所以非常感谢
mean to me, but in summary, I just want you to know how much I love you both. And the Nadia sent in a bunch of questions, and one of the ones we want to answer today is, do you guys ever feel weird seeing your face on merchandise or wallpapers? And she also said, P.S. Angela, I love your diary. It's one of my favorite things ever. Nadia, first of all, we just want to say thank you for all those kind words. Yes. I can't even tell you what it means to me that the podcast brings you peace and comfort. Yeah. And that you feel seen and. heard and we love doing this podcast and we really love our office ladies family. So thank you so
你成为其中的一部分。还有，是的，在周边商品和壁纸上看到自己的脸确实很怪异。我不确定我是否已经习惯了。这只是很奇怪，而且它总是出现在最随机的地方。我想我以前分享过。有一次我姐姐珍妮给我发短信，她当时在T.J. Max。她说：“你的脸出现在一个烈酒杯上了。”是的。是的，这真的很疯狂，而且这些年来一直都在持续。好吧，你们听说现在他们把《办公室》的角色变成《堡垒之夜》皮肤了吗？我听说过这个。
much for being part of it. And also, yes, it is weird seeing my face on merchandise and wallpapers. I'm not sure I've ever gotten used to it. It's just weird and it's, it pops up in the most random places. I think I've shared this before. One time my sister Janet texted me and she was at T.J. Max. And she said, and your face is on a shot glass. Yeah. Yeah, it is just really wild and it's has just kept going all these years. Well, did you hear now they're turning the office characters into Fortnite skins? I did hear this.
我的儿子们告诉我。好吧，德怀特和迈克尔已经出了。吉姆和帕姆要出了。我不知道他们还会不会出更多的。而且，你知道，我想让大家知道的一件事是，我是从新闻里发现这一点的。好像没人问过我。我没必要批准。我对此一分钱也拿不到。
My sons told me. Well, Dwight and Michael are out. Jim and Pam are coming out. I don't know if they're going to do more. And, you know, something I want to let everyone know is that I found this out in the news. Like, nobody asked me. I didn't have to give permission. I don't get paid anything for it.
好吧，我们谁也没有。没有。整个无论什么，无论他们在哪里展示做什么，我们都拿不到钱。没有，这也是件奇怪的事。是啊。因为你只是觉得到处都是你的脸。但我想，真的，作为一个《堡垒之夜》皮肤，我的脸我什么也得不到。我想这“姑且算是”帕姆。
Well, none of us do. No. The whole entire, whatever, whoever they feature anywhere doing stuff, we don't get paid for it. No, which is also weird. Yeah. Because you just feel like your face is everywhere. But I was like, really, I don't get anything for my face as a fortnight skin. And I guess it's quote unquote, Pam.
不是我。但我就觉得，只是因为那是穿着粉红色毛衣的我的脸。所以只要你把我的脸放进粉红色毛衣里，那就不是我，那是帕姆，然后我什么也得不到。NBC拿了钱。我觉得这很奇怪。抱歉，我觉得这很奇怪。是啊。
It's not me. But I'm like, but just because it's my face. in a pink sweater. Like, so anytime you take my face and put it in a pink sweater, it's not me, it's Pam, and then I don't get anything for it. NBC gets the money. I find that weird. I'm sorry, I find it weird. Yeah.
我不明白为什么我们分不到一杯羹。这确实很奇怪。每次都觉得很怪。好吧，你知道，有时候这就是我们清晰的脸，你知道吗？就像这样。这简直就是我们的照片。是啊。不过不管怎样，娜迪亚，这确实有点奇怪。
I don't understand why we don't get a cut of that. It is weird. It's just weird every time. Well, you know, it's like sometimes it's just so clearly our face, you know? It's like so like. It's literally a picture of us. Yeah. But anyway, Nadia, it is kind of odd.
确实。而且我一直觉得很有趣的是，他们找到的把我们的脸印在各种东西上的不同方式。就像这个《堡垒之夜》皮肤、烈酒杯或浴巾。你们俩还记得第一次看到自己的脸印在什么东西上吗？就像《办公室》刚播的时候，你知道的，第一季、第二季，周边商品开始推出的时候？哦，天哪，这是个好问题。我知道纽约的NBC商店
It is. And I think what's always interesting to me is the different ways they find to put our faces on things. Like this Fortnite skins and a shot glass or a bath towel. Do either of you remember the first thing that you saw your face on? Like when the office, you know, like season one, season two, like when merch started rolling out? Oh, gosh. that's a good question. I know that the NBC store in New York
有一个吉姆和帕姆的马克杯什么的。那是情人节前后。我记得约翰和我去了纽约，做了一个小型宣传活动，我们在NBC商店里。我说：“哦，天哪，约翰，我们在这个马克杯上。”是啊。所以那可能是我第一次看到自己
had like a Jim and Pam mug or something. And it was around Valentine's Day. And I remember John and I went to New York and we did like a little press thing and we were in the NBC store. And I was like, oh my gosh, John, we're on this mug. Yeah. So maybe that was the first time I saw my son.
作为周边商品出现。好吧。是的，我想对我来说，是NBC推出了这些小情人节卡片。哦，好吧。上面有德怀特和安吉拉。迈克尔·斯科特周围都是女士们。他举着一颗心。是啊。
as merch. Okay. Yeah, I think for me, it was NBC put out these little Valentine's cards. Oh, okay. And it had Dwight and Angela. It had the ladies all around Michael Scott. He's holding up a heart. Yeah.
你可以买到这些小情人节卡片。我被它逗乐了。我真的是高兴极了。我想，娜迪亚，我想让你知道的是：我喜欢那些能用创意方式重现我们角色的粉丝。我太喜欢所有的粉丝艺术了。而且有时候，你会觉得自己成了某个大型企业机器的一部分，比如《堡垒之夜》皮肤。这感觉不一样。
And there were these little Valentine's cards you could buy. And I was so tickled by it. I really was just so delighted. And I think the thing, Nadia, I would want you to know, it's like, I love fans that find creative ways to recreate our characters. I love all the fan art so much. And I think sometimes, though, you feel like you're part of some big corporate machine when it's like Fortnite skins. It's different.
有点不同，你知道的？是啊。但我喜欢粉丝对剧中角色的诠释。我也喜欢人们制作东西送给我们。真的很酷。但当你走在某个地方，你的脸却印在T.J. Max的烈酒杯上时。你会想：等等，怎么会这样？我觉得这一点说得很好，安吉拉。
It's a little different, you know? Yeah. But I love fans' interpretations of the characters on the show. And I love it when people make us stuff and send it to us. It's really cool. But when you're out just walking around somewhere and your face is on like a T.J. Max shot blast. You're like, wait, how did that happen? I think that's a good point, Angela.
我支持每一个粉丝诠释我们的角色并制作出超酷物品的Etsy店铺。是啊。而且通常那些东西也酷得多。是啊。我想你是对的。就像当大型跨国公司因为把你的脸印在某样东西上而赚取大量资金，然后这只变成又一个大型跨国公司在瓜分资金。我是说，我更愿意让某个酷炫的Etsy艺术家赚点钱。是啊。
I am here for every Etsy shop where a fan has interpreted our characters and made some super cool thing. Yeah. And usually that stuff is way cooler, too. Yeah. I think you're right. It's like when the big mega corporation is getting a bunch of money because they put your face on something and then it's just another big mega corporation splitting all the funds. Like, I'd much rather some, like, cool Etsy artist get some Moolah. Yeah.
你知道我在说什么吗？绝对的。是啊。所以Etsy的朋友们，我们支持你们。继续加油。是啊。好吧，听着，这就是我们所有的内容，除了我们还有最后一件事。
You know what I'm saying? Absolutely. Yeah. So Etsy, folks, we're here for you. Keep it up. Yeah. All right. Well, listen, that's all we've got, except we have one more thing.
那个有着糟糕航海纹身的匿名名人给你回信了吗？我看见你在那边发短信了。他回了。他回了。首先，他写道：“是的。我还在留着它。哈哈哈哈哈哈。”然后他说：“那个纹身师太帅太酷了。
Did the anonymous celebrity with the lame nautical tattoo get back to you? I've seen you texting over there. He did. He did. And first of all, he wrote, yes. I still have it. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. And then he said, the tattoo artist was so handsome and cool.
我不想让他失望。”然后他说我可以透露他是谁，他还给我发了一些音频。不会吧。哦，天哪。拥有糟糕航海纹身的独家名人就是奥利弗·哈德森。奥利弗。我绝对猜不到。我们开始吧。
I didn't want to disappoint him. And then he said I could reveal who he is, and he sent me in some audio. No way. Oh, my gosh. Exclusive celebrity with lame nautical tattoo is Oliver Hudson. Oliver. I would never have guessed. Here we go.
所以我多年来一直想为我的孩子们纹个身，但一直不知道具体是什么。我知道因为我对海洋的热爱，我想要某种航海风格的东西。我想要点与众不同的、很酷的东西，而不是那种老式的标准船锚。我去找了这个人，我不说他的名字，因为我不想贬低他。他是个不可思议的艺术家。毫无疑问，这只是不太符合他的专长，我想。不管怎样，我去了。他把设计好的模板贴在我身上。
So I wanted to get a tattoo for my kids for years and didn't really know what it was. I knew I wanted something nautical because of my love for the ocean. I wanted something a little different, something cool, not your standard old school anchor. And I went to this guy, I don't say his name, because I don't want to disson. He's an incredible artist. Like, there's no doubt it just wasn't his forte, I guess. Anyway, I went there. he put the stencil on me that he sort of came up with.
老实说，我当时并不是很感觉得劲，但他太酷了、极其帅气而且浑身都是纹身，以至于我对提出任何修改意见感到很不自在。我说：“嗯，如果我们这样做会怎么样？”然后他做了点别的，贴上了另一个模板。我当时就说：“行吧”，尽管我心里想的是：“哦，天哪。不要。”然后我躺在桌子上。
And it just, well, I wasn't really feeling it, but he was so cool and extremely handsome and all tatted up that I felt like insecure about making any changes. And I said, well, what if we did this? And he did something else and put another stencil on. I was like, yeah, even though I was like, oh, my God. No. And then I get on the table.
四个小时后，它就印在我的手臂上了。看起来像个枝形吊灯。它看起来不像是船锚。它看起来像是美丽宴会厅里的大型枝形吊灯。但它现在永远留在我身上了。我消沉了很长一段时间。现在我只是偶尔才会消沉一下。他大概会想：“谢谢你又把它提起来。”
Four hours later, I have it on my arm. And it looks like a chandelier. It doesn't look like an anchor. It looks like a grand chandelier in a beautiful ballroom. But it's on me forever now. And I was depressed for a long time. And now I only get depressed every once in a while. He's probably like, thanks for bringing it back up.
伙计们，我太高兴他在音频里这么说了，因为我需要让你们知道，和奥利弗·哈德森合作就是这么令人愉快。如果你只想拥有最棒、最有趣的合作项目，你想雇佣奥利弗·哈德森。而且他非常有才华。他是如此搞笑。他在驾驭戏剧方面非常出色。我太喜欢他了。你应该分享你们俩一起合作《共度难关》（Splitting Up Together）的经历。
You guys, I'm so glad he said that in, Because I just need you to know that is the delight that it is to work with Oliver Hudson. If you just want to have the best, most fun project, you want to hire Oliver Hudson. And he's so talented, too. Like, he's so funny. He's so good with drama. I adore him so much. And you should share you guys work together on splitting up together.
是的，拍了两季的电视剧。是啊。我们的剧以一个巨大的悬念结束了，因为我们被砍了。我们有一个巨大的悬念。我们都确信我们会拍到第三季，然后他们把我们砍了。这太令人沮丧了。我和鲍比·李一起合作的。是啊。是啊。很棒的团队。奥利弗，非常感谢。我现在真的很想看一张照片。我不知道他是否愿意给我们发一张照片，但枝形吊灯根本不是我一直以来脑海中的画面。我知道。也许我没有描述好。我的记忆。你描述得很完美。
Yes, for two seasons of a TV show. Yeah. And we ended her show on like this giant cliffhanger because we got canceled. We had this big cliffhanger. We were all sure we were going to get to season three and then they canceled us. And it was such a bummer. I worked on that with Bobby Lee. Yeah. Yeah. Great group. Oliver, thank you so much. I really need to see a picture now. I don't know if he'd be up for sending us a picture, but chandelier is not the image I had in my head this whole time. I know. Maybe I didn't describe it very well. My memory. You described it perfectly.
是吗？是啊。好的。哦，天哪，奥利弗，谢谢你。你知道吗？你得来。你得来跟我们一起上《办公室女士》。他真的得来。那绝对会是最好的时光。好吧，各位，那是《办公室新闻》和《勒索》。希望你们喜欢。是啊。查看链接和简介，了解各种好玩的东西。哦，在这里。对不起。他刚发过来。他刚发过来。我想看。他刚发照片了。我得看看。对不起。转过来。萨姆·乔丹。比我记忆中的还要糟糕。对不起。
Did I? Yeah. Okay. Oh my gosh, Oliver, thank you. And you know what? You got to come. You got to come hang with us on office ladies. He really does. It would be the absolute best time. Well, you guys, that was Office News and Blackmail. We hope you enjoyed it. Yeah. Check out the link and bio for all kinds of cool stuff. Oh, here it is. I'm sorry. He just sent it. He just sent it. I want to see it. He just sent a photo. I need to see it. I'm sorry. Turn it around. Sam Jordan. It's worse than I remember. I'm sorry.
你看到了吗？看到了。就像多个船锚。那是多个挂着的船锚。上面还点缀着珠宝。就像挂在船锚上的多个船锚，还带有一个字母“H”。好吧，因为他有三个孩子。就像他去了一家非常高级的海军……
Do you see it? I do. It's like multiple anchors. It's multiple anchors hanging. It's like adorned with jewels. It's like multiple anchors hanging off an anchor with like also the letter H. Well, because he has three kids. It's like he went to a very fancy Navy.
所以我想那是三个船锚。伙计们，太大了。占了他手臂的好大一部分。我能看看吗？哦，天哪，太巨大了。占了他整个二头肌。我喜欢，如果你放大看，他正微微地做着痛苦的表情。哦，奥利弗，我太爱你了。我太爱你了。我要对今天光临的乔丹·达菲表示由衷的感谢。
So I think it's three anchors. It's so large, you guys. So much of his arms. Can I see? Oh my God, it's enormous. It's his whole bicep. And I like if you zoom in, he's grimacing just a bit. Oh, Oliver, I love you so much. I love you so much. I want to say a quick thank you to Jordan Duffy for coming in today.
只要萨姆旅行或离开城镇，她就会在这里。乔丹，非常感谢。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你们大家。很高兴能在力所能及的时候帮忙。耶！耶！好了，各位。我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey的节目，由詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。
She is going to be here whenever Sam has to travel or go out of town. Jordan, thanks so much. It was great to see you. It was so great seeing you guys too. I'm so happy to be helping out when I can. Yay! Yay! All right, everyone. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，副制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。节目由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。你知道，很多时候你会看到一些根本不适合你的广告。你会想：为什么我会看到这个？很多B2B营销广告都被浪费在了错误的人身上。
Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. You know, a lot of times you get ads that are just not meant for you. You're like, why am I getting this? And a lot of times those business-to-business marketing ads get wasted on the wrong people.
嗯，LinkedIn可不想成为那种发送未做精准定位、并非意向受众的广告的发起者。他们已经积累了超过10亿职场专业人士和1.3亿决策者的网络，这正是它与其他广告投放的区别所在。首先，你可以按职位头衔、行业、公司、职位级别、资历、技能和公司收入来精准定位你的买家。因此你可以停止在错误的受众身上浪费预算。如果你想触达正确的专业人士，请使用LinkedIn广告。这就是为什么LinkedIn广告在所有在线广告网络中产生最高的B2B投资回报率（ROAS），真的是所有的网络。在LinkedIn广告上为你的第一场活动花上250美元，即可为下一场活动获得价值250美元的免费额度。
Well, LinkedIn doesn't want to be one of those people that's sending out an ad that's not targeted, that's not intended. They have grown a network of over one billion professionals and 130 million decision makers, and that is where it stands apart from other ad buys. First of all, you can target your buyers by job title, industry, company, role, seniority, skills, and company revenue. So you can stop wasting budget on the wrong. wrong audience. If you want to reach the right professionals, use LinkedIn ads. It's why LinkedIn ads generate the highest business-to-business ROAS of all online ad networks, seriously all of them. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a free $250 credit for the next one.
只需访问LinkedIn.com/office。即 LinkedIn.com/office。条款和条件适用。
Just go to LinkedIn.com slash office. That's LinkedIn.com slash office. Terms and conditions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。